What is that gadget?
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by the flashlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on
the link for the fleshlight and entering
the code name,
Rogan,
you would get 15% off the number one sex
toy from men as if there's some fucking
competition is there,
you know,
there's,
is there a battle?
The sex toys,
I saw one the other day that you can put
it in the dishwasher and it was pretty
bad ass looking,
but it vibrated and I
don't think vibrating.
That's not real life.
Yeah.
I don't need a vibrating
and fix the Jina anyway.
If you enter in the code
name Rogan and get 15% off.
And if you go to a,
also we're sponsored by [inaudible] Dot
Com oh and it makers of Alpha brain,
we have a new alpha brain,
uh,
for people in Europe where it's illegal
to sell vitamin B six in some parts of
the world.
Yeah.
And a couple of other nutrients.
So we replaced them with
legal ones in those countries.
So there's a new Alpha brain
for folks that live in Europe.
It's called Alpha brain source.
And that she would,
I really soon,
we also have the court accepts mushrooms,
Supplement shroom tech sport,
which is great for people that are like,
if you're into really working out,
if you really like,
like,
uh,
you know,
really hard working out,
that's good for you.
If not,
if you're one of those Brian characters,
he's not necessarily right and you don't
need those trim tech sport and your
life.
There's no need.
We also have shroom tech immune,
which is a great immune immunity
booster and it's good stuff.
It's,
I don't know the science behind it,
so I can't really explain.
But as it was explained to me what it
is is something in this mushroom tricks
your immune system and the thinking that
it's like a cold and your immune system
pumps up and prepares for
a fight that never comes.
And so,
and it has zinc in it,
honestly,
has a bunch of stuff and it's
good for your immune system.
And we also make a new mood,
which is a five HTP supplement,
which is,
um,
just gives you like a
little serotonin boost.
It makes you feel good.
Again,
uh,
all the stuff that we
sell@onnit.com I always say,
if you,
if you like anything,
it's too expensive.
Please just buy the ingredients somewhere
else cheaper and put it all together
yourself.
Steal the ingredient list online,
copy it and replicate it
and enjoy yourself were,
you know,
more concerned about not ripping anybody
off and you're not buying something
that you don't want to buy that
I can't overstate this enough.
That's why also there's a hundred
percent money back guarantee.
If you don't like anything,
you don't have to return it.
You just tell us you don't like it
and you get 100% of your money back.
It's really that simple.
I think what we're selling is good shit.
If you go to [inaudible] dot com it's
o and n it and entering the code name
rogue and you get 10% off.
All right,
kids strapped the fuck in.
I hope you've prepared yourself.
I hope you sacrifice the sacred plant
to the fire Gods because Michael ropers
here,
bitches,
we're going to get to
the bottom of some shit.
This,
this is an unusual,
very unusual man that's with us today.
First of all,
thank you very much for doing this man.
I really appreciate it.
It's an honor.
I bought your book.
You,
me a copy of it today,
but I already have it cause I
bought it about five years ago,
which is crossing the Rubicon.
That's when it came out,
right?
When,
when did I,
uh,
August of a
bowl for
when I first became aware of you
was that speech that you gave,
I don't know where you were,
but as a speech that
you gave where you were,
you were talking in front of a,
some judge and some sort of a courtroom
somewhere and you were explaining how
you were an la police department officer
and you caught the CIA selling drugs
and you were just fucking saying it.
You were just standing
in front of this judge.
What was that instance?
[inaudible] who was that?
That was a,
you're a fighter and,
you know,
war and battle and stuff.
This was one of those
certain circumstances.
One,
uh,
one of my favorite,
um,
axioms about combat,
about fighting somebody was,
was given to me by a
chief warrant officer.
Four from Armenia,
from army criminal intelligence division.
You don't shoot unless
you get a head shot.
And I had the head shot that day on the
director of Central Intelligence and it,
you know,
it's,
it's Kinda like something that you can
spend your whole life in a fight or
combat waiting for everything to line up,
but you know,
when it lines up and it's like,
that's what happened.
So 18 years I had been trying to,
uh,
make somebody pay attention to the fact
that CIA had been bringing drugs into
the United States.
Um,
and,
uh,
and I had lost a career because I blew
a whistle on that and I'd been 18 years
and I finally got a
chance to nail the guy.
That seems so crazy that you're the
first guy to come out with that.
I mean,
I've know,
I've heard stories before
and I know I knew about the,
um,
the Mena Arkansas situation with a,
what was that gentleman's name?
Clinton.
Indiana.
Clin 10.
Terry Reed and the other dude,
the dude that got caught that
was over that Barry seal.
Barry Seal.
That's the guy.
He's the guy who died with George Bush,
has phone number in his pocket.
You know,
I mean,
that's a fascinating story.
There's a guy who says that he was
bringing in drugs for the CIA for a long
time,
right from South America.
And they would have a spot where they
would drop it off and apparently two kids
saw it and these two kids,
they killed these two kids.
And then they said it was suicide,
was the train track,
the train track desk.
So the parents fought for some sort of
an autopsy and the autopsy found out that
these kids had been murdered and then
it just spirals into this thing on
whining.
But who would have ever believed
before there was something like that?
I mean,
that's a big,
that was a really big case.
Well,
I,
yeah,
I came out with it publicly after I
resigned from LAPD in November 78.
Um,
and I resigned because chief gates
was going to let me get killed and he
wouldn't give me back up.
And you know,
and it was,
it was really six scenario.
I had perfect rating
reports and all this stuff.
So then I resigned and then
I went to the La Times.
So my clock on being public started in 79.
Uh,
but here's what's interesting
about all of that stuff.
You go back,
CIO has been dealing drugs ever since
before there was a CIA long story.
It's,
it's an economic issue more
than it is anything else.
It's just something
where they can't pass up.
It's just too much money.
It's going out there anywhere.
Um,
and it helps them do things that
they don't have to get approved.
Right.
Well,
that's only part of it.
Uh,
you have to remember that Bill Casey,
Ronald Reagan,
CIA director was a stockbroker.
The CIA was created by a,
the Dulles brothers,
John Foster and Alan Dallas,
um,
who were partners in Sullivan chrome.
Well,
they created,
founded the CIA,
Allen Dulles is,
so it's the Cin Wall Street have
always been one in the same thing.
And to deal with drug money,
which one I wrote,
a lot of the stuff that's
in Rubicon is that,
um,
you can move it with profits to earning
ratios off books in a crooked economic
paradigm and with price to earnings.
If,
if you launder $1 million worth
of drug money onto a corporation,
let's say,
Gee,
you as a price to earnings of 30 to one,
you've just created $30
million in stock value.
There's a huge multiplier.
And the CIA,
this is all part of the same correct,
corrupt economic paradigm
which is destroying us.
Now that's the case that I started on
then trying to find out what the fuck is
going on around here.
How did you find out and did other people
know and just keep their mouth shut?
Like how did you,
how did you know,
how was their like ultimate proof to you?
Well,
uh,
well when I saw it with
my eyeballs was proof,
but see how I got into,
it's a completely different deal.
Um,
I have a special birth.
My mother was a senior crypt analyst for
the Army Security Agency in World War
II.
Her work product went
to Secretary of state,
secretary of war and
President Roosevelt highest,
she worked on Japanese codes,
the Russian codes.
Okay.
My father was a decorated air force,
a hero of veteran.
He was in [inaudible] World War II.
Then it came up on all this stuff
and he both were connected with CIS.
I came from a CIF family.
So I mean I used to come
home from grade school and,
and say,
mom,
what's for dinner?
And she'd say,
I can't tell you.
Ah,
Gotcha.
So,
so anyway,
uh,
so I was marked and plus I was gifted,
you know,
I was a good smart guy and so I was being
groomed because the CIA has people in
police departments all over the
country and they have for years.
Laura Nola,
that's what they do.
So I was being recruited into that
because I already had a cute clearance,
which I had had just from
living with my parents.
And so that kind of marked me as
somebody who would like on the inside,
but I wasn't really,
you know,
I wasn't going to go along with
drugs one when that's what I saw,
what it was.
I wouldn't do it.
And everybody else who's
just going along with it,
or do they just turn a blind dog?
There's,
how does it mean?
How has it,
how does it go?
How does it work?
Well,
what happens is that,
I'm sure you understand this,
this is that,
uh,
we w w we live in a world
that's full of sell outs.
We're surrounded by sell
outs.
We're surrounded by a,
and this came up really recently with,
with,
with occupy and my French and Mark
Thomas and all this stuff that we got
together involved with that.
It's about honor.
Um,
and,
uh,
some people just aren't
capable of selling out,
I guess.
And I guess I'm one of those,
but most people resign themselves.
And not everybody knows this.
Like,
not every LAPD cop knows this happens,
you know,
it's compartmentalize.
But,
uh,
there's a lot of people out there in
law enforcement and I think we've seen
this,
uh,
with the occupy movement of the way
veterans and some cops have responded to.
There's a lot of people inside the
system who were really honest and they're
just waiting for somebody else
to show them how to do it.
Wow.
What a terrifying situation.
So you're the first guy to step up and
you step up and step out and say that in
front of all these people on television,
what happens then?
Yeah.
I'm not so sure I was
the first to step up.
I'm like that.
Well,
I was the first to do it and stay alive
and the first to do it and find a way to
get shit like this done.
Do you think it's almost safer to come
out with something like that than it is
to be the guy who hasn't said
anything and they could silence?
Yeah,
I mean,
yeah,
being transparent publicly is
your absolute best offense.
And that's something I've
done for 35 years now.
But you got to a point in one point,
were you appointed one point where you,
where you were worried
about your own life,
like you left the country for awhile,
right?
Many times I've,
I've never not really been,
uh,
that you like one of those dudes like
wakes up and hears something and just
fucking packed your bags.
He gets on a plane.
No,
I mean,
how many times did you do it?
No.
Oh
Uh,
uh,
you make peace with it.
You have to learn how to live with it.
Um,
one of my training officers that LAPD
had been a marine with the fifth marines
in the citadel at way,
and he said,
you can get used to anything.
And that was a,
that was a real teacher.
So it's not that you can't
live on adrenaline forever,
you know,
so you make peace and then,
but being public is,
uh,
is,
is always the best safety.
Why were you worried about your life?
What was it specifically?
Well,
what,
what I,
what I would have,
what I was exposing.
Now you have to bear in mind that
when I was at LAPD and I resigned,
I had pulled like the tail
of something out of a hole.
I didn't know what was
attached to the rest of,
it's like,
I'm just gonna pull on this one
worm and Allston until I ended.
It's the,
it's the can of worms.
So,
uh,
but clearly what I had,
the CIA was directly involved in bringing
heroin into this country illegally of
using police officers in their pay or
control with the clearances to protect
those drug shipments.
And they were laundering the drug money.
Uh,
and,
and that it had to have been
known at a White House level.
And that was in 1970 78.
That's incredible.
And they thought that you just
keep getting away with it.
Well,
yeah.
But yeah,
those who went in a
rigged game gets stupid.
Yeah.
Those,
yeah.
I mean,
you know,
it's always fucking playing your way
and this and that get real sloppy.
It's true.
Wow,
that's a
brilliant point.
I've never heard anybody put it that way,
but you're absolutely right.
It's just human nature.
Yeah.
And,
and what I say now,
you know,
with the collapse of human industrial
civilization as the dinosaurs are not
capable of being anything
other than dinosaurs.
Well it is certainly if you
look at what we're doing,
why we're struggling at home so badly,
we insist on engaging and all these
things overseas that are pay strange
dividends and we don't,
we don't,
you know,
there's nothing tangible about it.
But tangibly in this country right now,
like people were having a
really fucking hard time,
but yet all of this money and all these
resources are going overseas to fight
wars that almost no one agrees with.
And when you look at it like
that is just sloppiness.
That just seems sloppy.
It's this,
it's so preposterous.
I mean it's so without merit.
Like if there wasn't some sort of a nine
11 attack and you propose this sort of
a ridiculous war,
everybody but like get
the fuck outta here.
But because of the initial nine 11 attack,
because there was something so big,
they capitalized on it.
And now they have written the
bad intentions right into the,
when you were on Leno
recently with Ron Paul,
I saw the great segment.
I mean like,
Ooh.
So,
uh,
but what I caught him and,
and I've been doing it.
I,
you know,
I've met Ron Paul and know him.
We're not good friends.
He's been in a film I made,
but I've tracked him for
a long time when we're,
when Ron Paul said,
um,
now the White House is trying to tell us
that Iran had something to do when with
nine 11.
Well,
that's what they ended.
The audience went berserk.
The collective
consciousness and waking up,
everybody here is like,
wait,
filled right up to here,
right up to here right now.
And they're just ready.
And,
and really that's why I think Ron Paul
such a threat right now because of Ron
Paul wins in Iowa,
not would,
uh,
it's a whole new political ballgame in
this country because that all of a sudden
it's,
it's going to be the norm,
a substantial norm for people to see
somebody like Ron Paul not believing all
that bull shit,
then it's safe for them.
How rig do you think voting is,
uh,
do you think is rigged at all?
Do you think it's 100% legitimate?
Well,
you think it's rigged still.
Listen,
after 2000 and I've been an investigative
journalist for a long time and I've
done a lot of writing about this.
They took the election 2000 was
stolen election 2004 choice point,
Dee Dee bold,
all the software and all that.
I watched that documentary
making democracy.
Unbelievable.
So fascinating.
But they can rig within certain,
because there are people
who see the polling places.
There are people and people know,
you know,
we had 80 people come in who are on Paul.
So they can't just say if
80% of the people vote green,
the 80% voted red cause
nobody would believe it.
Right.
All right.
So I think that Ron Paul is so far,
way much further ahead than
he's being shown in the polls.
I really think that there is a,
let's say Ron Paul is in
the forties and 50s and I,
which they wouldn't dare
let be known the and,
and the point is,
if he wins are wins with a landslide.
It's,
it's now Democrats and
Republicans no more.
It's Ron,
Paul and the Democrats
and the Republicans.
So we've got a whole new paradigm.
Wow,
I won.
Yeah.
So he has to win by such a substantial
margin that they can't fake it.
It has to almost be unanimous.
But you know,
it's so far,
the frightening thing to a lot
of people about it is the dis,
the sheer change that,
or a Ron Paul would bring about.
And you know,
that a real change like that is
absolutely terrifying to people.
Even though they know that the situation
right now is completely fucked up.
Completely unfair.
The congress is bought,
everything is stolen.
It's a total wreck.
They would still,
they're terrified of change.
It's terrified.
Not so much anymore.
You've got to get beaten into
a state of reasonableness.
You think it's the,
it's at the tipping point.
We're at the collapse of human industrial
civilization says 2008 that the world
is turned inside out several times.
It's getting nothing but worse.
And people are,
you know,
one of the best lines I heard
out of the occupy movement was,
uh,
somebody was asking the protesters are
moving along in New York and what are you
protesting?
And this really attractive,
smart woman says everything.
Everything,
everything is corrupt.
Everything is a lie.
Everything is bogus.
And all,
you know,
there's a lot of us that can see that.
Is it gotten worse or have
people just gotten more aware?
Both.
So it's accelerating as well as people
picking up on the rate of chain.
Now you gotta remember I'm,
I'm this guy,
it's been at this 35 years and you
don't want it to look so healthy.
You should be a fucking mess.
Oh,
I am.
The amount of stress.
But you look fine.
I eat really good.
Yeah.
I,
I'm on two and a half acres
in northern California.
Outside of Sebastopol.
Permaculture,
you grow your own.
Well,
we're growing food and I eat raw organic.
I go out and pick a raw salad out of my
garden and just eat it after you pick
the leaf.
Oh Wow.
And uh,
and so I eat good.
Uh,
and other than that I'm maybe good genes
and I spent a lot of time working out
and training over and over the years,
you know,
to,
uh,
I had to and I hung with some
really cool people along the way.
Right now my,
I have a bad rotator cuff here.
The cartilage is gone,
so I can't work out too much.
Oh really?
Yeah,
yeah.
That's a drag.
We're shoulder injuries or
they're very complicated,
very difficult to fix.
A lot of people have shoulder issues,
becomes a big problem till
they have surgery on it.
And even then like surgery,
now they're pretty good at it.
But back in the day,
if you had a shoulder issue,
it was a big one.
It's just such a,
such a complicated joint.
But that's a,
so that's the way you blew off steam.
But I can't imagine being under
that kind of pressure,
having,
knowing that people were upset at me
knowing what I w you know what you said,
you know about all these
fucking bad people and your,
you know,
okay.
And you,
you,
you're,
you're out there,
you know,
exposed constantly,
uh,
you know,
doing radio interviews,
constantly doing,
you know,
um,
uh,
I wouldn't have been able to do any
of this without my spiritual life and,
and,
and some very deep and
profound spiritual practices.
A,
I'm a guy in,
I believe that this planet is alive.
A guy in a guy.
What kind of,
what does this is like a religion?
Yeah.
Guy At mother earth.
She's alive.
You know,
isn't it interesting that,
uh,
you,
you take the planets out from the sun,
Mercury is a god.
Venus is a goddess squat bar.
Mars is it got every other
planet is a god or a goddess,
except for this one.
Why?
Her name is Gloria.
She's alive.
So,
um,
is this something that's
actually written down as,
as an ideology or is it just your,
you have a philosophy behind it kind of
originated with Dr. James Lovelock and,
and it's,
uh,
it's,
it's new and it's also very old.
You know,
I'm,
I'm also,
I've also studied native American
spirituality quite a bit.
And,
and it's,
it's exactly the same thing.
Yeah.
Well,
it seems to me that we have a pretty
limited idea of what life is or what's
conscious.
You know,
we feel like if it can't
react and communicate with us,
it can't be conscious.
But there's,
you know,
a,
apparently there's been some studies
that show that it's very possible that
plant's recognize people when they're in
the room and they feel energy and they
can actually react to someone
doing something to them.
You know,
they might have some sort of
consciousness that we can't understand.
We just only assume that consciousness,
human consciousness,
there might be rock consciousness.
I mean,
everything might have a consciousness.
It might just be enabled
to express itself.
And the idea of this has a giant
super organism is so fascinating.
Oh yeah.
It's so amazing because
we know that everything,
nothing exists on its own.
I mean,
every single body is a mixture of
all sorts of different bacteria,
microbiotic particles and all sorts of
different things that are constantly
helping you.
Or macrobiotic,
you know,
like when you eat,
you're eating yogurt,
you know,
you're taking in troops.
You know,
when you taking the Acidophilus,
you're bringing in healthy animals,
living organisms.
I mean,
it's so fascinating that we absolutely
need that in order to stay healthy and be
alive.
One of the things I just did
[inaudible] was a very cool,
I live in the West Sonoma County,
uh,
and I,
there's a spa and I had,
I had done it like three months
without a day off for collapsed.
That,
that's,
that's my,
my,
uh,
company and doing the radio show.
And so I treated myself and they have a
spa where you go and you actually take a
bath in a hot living compost pile
and it's specially bred complex,
but the,
everything is alive and
it's warm and you become,
and it just,
it just,
it sucks stuff out of you
that's just really cool.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's freaky.
They said it's so weird though.
What a,
a s a different,
you know,
we're like a soup,
we're not just one ingredient and it's
really fascinating and the think of the
earth as being that just the
expressing itself in a larger way.
There's a great movie that just came
out this year called Anima Mundi,
m,
U N D I a out of Australia
and it's got big names.
I've got Noam Chomsky in it.
It's got a whole bunch and
it's all about [inaudible].
And there was some tremendous,
uh,
tremendous awakening things in
the [inaudible] you just look at.
And the science is really
good to support that to see.
I think the big problem is now is if,
let's say you and I are
Martians or from another planet,
we just came down here to check out
what's happened and what these creatures
down here,
right?
And the first thing that like,
well,
they're insane.
They're destroying the place.
Right?
You know,
and,
and that's all we have to live on.
So what are they doing?
They're shifting where the,
and I really think that
that originates with,
uh,
genesis one.
I mean,
I'm,
I'm at war with God,
or at least the religion
to the god of old,
the guys that brought us to this point.
And,
and,
and I'm at war with the God that
gave Man Dominion over the planet.
Bullshit.
That's why we're destroying it.
We'd been separated from it.
We were taught that we,
and,
and I don't believe that that's true.
And I believe that if there's any one
lie that's enabled all this corruption,
uh,
a lot of it to be hidden
under the guise of religion.
Uh,
that's,
that's the big one.
So you think then if you can get enough
people to recognize this earth as a
living thing,
we could change the way people
behave and change the practices.
So it doesn't seem to be,
it doesn't seem to have been that long
ago people didn't destroy the earth at
all.
But you know,
just a few hundred years ago,
the oceans were clean,
right?
I mean,
how many,
how many hundreds of
years ago was there were,
was there no pollution?
No.
You would have to go back probably to
the 12 hundreds earth know that there was
a,
there was part of it in,
in Rome.
Yeah.
Uh,
poop.
But let's go back 40,000 years ago.
Okay.
And then are our ancestors who
were going og or whoever the F,
you know,
um,
well first they were
living their religion.
24,
seven.
There was not a textbook.
So you didn't,
nobody persuaded them,
converted them.
That's just the way they live.
The earth was the Bible.
Wow.
Okay.
Some things are sacred and you know,
there are things that you don't do,
like stick your finger
into a light socket.
Thou shalt not because you know,
it hurts or you die.
And there were rules in nature.
Thou shalt not stay out in the cold and
over x number of hours or after this was
that that was the religion
because it was a direct feedback.
Well,
I've always felt the native American
ideal of using every single bit of the
animal that you kill in,
in,
in honor of the animal.
That there's something
very important about that.
I went to,
uh,
it's fair,
Tom Brown of Tom Brown tracker schools,
a friend of mine and I
went to his Drucker school,
maximize sister and I went to
his tracker school in February.
And that's,
that's what they teach too,
you know,
but,
but anyway,
so our ancestors 40,000
years ago running around,
right,
they didn't all of a sudden
stop one day and going,
why am I having this wilderness
experience that was all north.
That was so what,
what Mankiw's task is now with the
collapse of human industrial civilization,
which is here,
which cannot be stopped,
um,
is not so much to learn,
but to remember stuff that
we've known inside of us.
Um,
forever and you've got to clear
a lot of garbage out of the way,
you know,
to get there.
And,
uh,
I'm pretty optimistic about what I see.
I mean,
I,
I started collapsing that
my company collapse net.com.
There's the plug.
Um,
and we're in 68 countries.
We're getting 40,000 visitors a day.
You're optimistic and won't way like the
collapse is going to be a good thing.
I know,
I'm seeing,
yeah,
people awakening.
I am seeing people,
uh,
the,
you know,
as I said in the movie collapsed.
Mankind's choice now is evolve or perish,
grow the fuck up or die because the
laws of nature cannot be overturned.
And that's the fundamental thing that's
wrong with this infinite growth paradigm
that we live in.
Okay,
we'll do that separate.
So,
um,
where was I?
All of that done all that done and that
world we live in is dying and there's a
new consciousness emerging.
Now,
my friend Colin Campbell,
who was one of the,
uh,
he's the Godfather,
that people well movement said that,
uh,
the species,
homo sapiens might not become extinct,
but the subspecies of petroleum man,
most certainly will.
Wow.
Okay.
So there's posts,
petroleum,
human,
and there's a new consciousness
emerging and there are,
there are tens of millions
of us around the world and,
and,
and truly I think there may be hundreds
of millions or a billion or more of us
around the world.
We just haven't been allowed
to see each other yet.
There's something with that matrix that
keeps you from seeing all the other
people who feel,
that's why with you and Ron Paul on a,
on Leno,
when the audience started cheering,
it was like that was a,
that was a bitch slap bucket of cold
water to the face of Barack Obama and
everybody in Washington,
you know,
who thought they could actually
get away with this stuff again,
you think Obama,
do you think Obama knew what was gonna
happen before he got into office?
Cause he seems,
it seems to me,
me seems so ineffective.
It's almost like he had an
idea of what it would be like.
And then when he got in,
there is just nothing like that.
Barack Obama's extremely effective.
He's extremely effective
for his client base,
which is the banks that
is a banking president and
there's no difference between
Democrat and Republican.
He,
Barack Obama had no intent,
you know,
he seemed like one of us when
he was running for president,
he seemed like one of us,
it seemed like he was going to,
you're not with microphones on elbow.
It's probably cause
he was,
you know,
he probably started off,
thank you.
I wanted to know.
I always wanted to know.
I mean,
it wouldn't have been Nama.
He wouldn't have ever gotten close to,
to the nomination unless his
loyalty had been secured.
Oh Wow.
It's so crabbing at that's real.
Yeah.
It's such a fucking Rina.
If it really is that rigged,
I mean,
it,
it's,
it's almost preposterous.
It's able to go on as long as it has.
I was,
uh,
I've,
I've had,
I've done a lot of shit.
I've been around a long time.
I was the press spokesman for Ross Perot.
Whoa.
In Los Angeles County in 1992 at a time
when Ross Perot was ahead of both George
Bush and Bill Clinton.
Remember that?
10 Poles.
Okay.
Hi,
I'm Ross Perot shorts,
floppy or texting with a big nose.
Remember when he took out that and
he basically bought a half an hour of
television in prime time and
explain what's wrong with,
what was it with the tax structure.
I forgot what it was,
but it was just and,
and,
uh,
the debt debt.
And he explained it
all and spelled it out.
And he's the only one that made any sense.
I mean,
he seemed like a crazy dude,
but everybody wants to be president.
It's crazy.
Well,
what,
what I'm saying with that is I've been
around presidential politics a long time
and I studied that a lot of ways.
My rubicons in the
Harvard BizLibrary okay.
So,
yeah,
it's that rate.
Yeah,
it is that Rick.
It's terrifying.
This is the freest country the
world has ever known and it's,
it's been fucking hoodwinked
by giant corporations.
We have been,
uh,
there was a guy,
I had a source,
somebody who was in a position to know
when William Casey had his first briefing
as DCI director of central intelligence
under Ronald Reagan would have been in
January of 81.
Um,
he said to those in the room,
he said,
we will know that we have been successful
when everything the American people
believe is true is false.
Wow.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
It's just amazing that
this has sort of been,
uh,
the way governments have done
things since the beginning.
So like no one has ever like been
straight with the people and had it all,
you know,
even,
and I mean it,
has there ever been a culture ever that
has been like completely cool as far as
the government goes and just
watched the movie last night,
the cove and even in that movie
was a movie about dolphins.
How much the Japanese government lied
to the people about mercury poisoning.
Yeah.
Well apparently that's what Shane Smith
from vice.com was telling us about the,
the,
the knelt down a much
more of a health issue.
Then the,
then the government is letting
on all of that stuff is cooked.
But
the reason why,
let's,
uh,
let's take a quote quote
from a Myer Rothchild.
I,
it was my senior Rothchild,
the guy who was a of the London house.
Oh.
He said,
ah,
give me control of a nation's currency.
It's money and I care
not who passes its laws,
who governs it.
It's
the infinite growth.
And look at what we're seeing around
us with the economic collapse,
the endless fucking corruption.
No,
it killed me when all was going down,
when the bailouts were happening and
Obama actually had the nerve to say that
there was going to limit the bonuses,
that these guys got to
half a million dollars.
You like w as if someone actually talked
him into thinking that that made any
sense to regular people.
The regular people going to go set up.
Yeah.
You know,
he had to get his half a mill.
He had to get,
the bank is falling apart.
People are bailing out the bank with
their tax dollars and then somehow or
another,
it's rig in the way that
the CEOs get bonuses.
What,
what?
How could that,
what did,
what does that bonus based on those
who win in a rigged game get stupid?
Barack Obama thinks people believe
that he actually killed Osama bin.
Fucking Loddon.
Nobody believes it.
I don't believe it.
No,
I'm not convinced.
There's too,
I've talked to too many military
people that don't believe it.
I've talked to people that,
you know,
probably shouldn't be talking
about it and they're like,
this is fucking horseshit.
We know that that guy has
been dead for years now.
This will please.
Yeah,
it was fire up.
You can take a shit on the floor if you
want your Michael Ruber do whatever you
gotta do buddy want you to be comfortable?
Well,
I'm pretty impressed that
he's smoking because,
and then maybe collapse.
He smoked probably like a
carton in the first 10 minutes.
No,
that's Chris Smith.
The director loved that film noire
effect and I can do the sexy thing,
but the cigarette obviously,
you know what I'm saying?
It gets more doom and gloom.
If you got it work at,
you know,
well you know,
if the end world's coming,
why not get cancer too?
And you go American spirits,
is that actually healthier,
much healthier.
There's no additives to that at all.
For folks who don't know
enjoy your cigarettes,
there's 599 different fucking things
that are added to cigarettes at our
government said we're cool with that.
Oh yeah,
you want to have more?
We'll see.
Well we have cigarettes and cigarettes
are pretty addictive but you know we came
out with some way to really fuck with
your neurotransmitters and make it like
super addictive and said okay we just
throw that in there from the gulf is safe
to eat too.
Let me,
yeah,
I saw commercials like the
Gulf's coming back and they're,
they're serving shrimp and I'm
looking at them like they're bombs.
Those sliding a shrimp bomb your way.
Like what is,
what the fuck is that man?
I hope it's okay.
But Jesus Christ,
how did they fix that all wheel problem?
Cause I heard they didn't,
I heard there's a new slick,
I heard that people
have seen other slicks,
you know,
did they,
I don't think it's completely capped off,
right.
Yeah,
I had a good friend,
Matthew seven scary,
a colleague who was a,
had been,
he had been the world's largest energy
investment banker and he was a colleague
of mine in the peak oil
movement for many years.
He died,
I think,
I won't say that yet,
but he,
he died under mysterious
circumstances to me.
Uh,
but he knew all about the golf and,
and it was a total blowout.
Know the seabed is destroyed.
He was telling the truth there.
There's the shaft from deep
water rise and it went down.
And,
and what's happened is,
is it,
the whole bed is now fractured
all around it and it's,
the oil is seeping up and there's no way,
there's no way to control it.
Oh my God.
So terrifying.
You know,
I was in New Orleans for the
first time recently and I really,
really enjoyed it.
Like what an unusual,
shitty,
what an amazing city really is.
One of the last few places
that has its own true identity.
You know,
when we're hanging around,
it was like what a great place it is.
And that's where I saw CIA
bringing drugs into the country.
That's,
that's why I where I became
an eyeball wit to it.
Jesus,
you northern.
Yeah,
New Orleans got some Mojo in
New Orleans and fun place,
man.
That's a fun place.
It's almost like it's another country.
Like you should have to have
a passport to get there.
It's like you're,
you're going to another country.
It's very strange or affected those
poor people get hit by that man,
you know,
after Katrina,
then they get hit by that and then,
you know,
wha how is the ocean now?
I mean so much ocean.
How long does it take
the sea bed is the issue,
right?
Is that what it is?
It'll destroy the food
chain because you're,
you know,
as if they had just stopped
what would got into the ocean,
the ocean would probably absorb it all.
Cause it's so enormous.
Well of course they were
lying about the quantity.
So,
I mean,
you know,
I had known it was over a hundred
thousand barrels a day early on and,
uh,
oh,
it was,
it was much higher than that one,
but a couple of points and
that's never been really fixed.
That's the problem with this
whole paradigm at that Fukushima.
Okay.
Japan is mortally wounded with radiation,
uh,
collapsed that my side,
we have been documenting,
you know,
tens,
hundreds of thousands of times,
greater levels of radiation
released over broader distances.
Cesium,
uh,
there's been a spike in mortality
in the U S as a result of Fukushima,
the 35% spike in a neonatal mortality,
uh,
right after Fukushima in Japan here,
Pacific northwest,
San Francisco,
north.
Um,
and,
and Japan is mortally wounded
with radiation and the
global food supply is now
contaminated as a result of the cesium,
uh,
the plutonium and,
you know,
baby food was just found detected
the other day with a radiation.
Yeah.
Really in Japan or in America?
Japan.
But that could have been
easily sent to America.
Do we buy their baby food?
I hope not.
Wow.
So how many fix that is it?
Is it possible to fix that area?
That area is fucked,
right?
Um,
it's going to go through the ground
for the next 30 or 40,000 years.
That's the half life of cesium.
So it's okay.
So yeah,
no,
that's,
it's permanently um,
unusable.
Uh,
and,
and what they're finding is that the
birds have a heavy Eaton radioactive seeds
and they're shitting out radioactive
poop all over New Zealand now.
Oh my God.
And so that's a mortal
wound to the global economy.
That's what we do at collapse collapse,
that I bring all this stuff all together
so we can get a real picture of how bad
things really are.
So is it safe to say the collapse
that is the last place you should go?
If you thinking about getting some sleep,
it's like 11 o'clock at night.
You're like,
man,
gets her shit.
I check online to see what's going on.
Let me head over to collapse.
Now you find yourself sweating and
making coffee at 5:00 AM if you go to his
website,
you immediately see this poor,
sad guy,
some dubious at the stock market,
watching his house explore what we become.
God's Melton is like,
we're with a place where occupy around
the world goes to find out what the
fuck's going on.
We're clearing house.
What really trustworthy,
useful information.
Right?
Right now I'm really tight with
the occupy folks and you know,
I'm,
I'm an occupier,
wasn't Santa Rosa,
you know,
and,
and uh,
and deeply is that the next civilization?
Cause you know,
this is one of the things
that I'm hearing from people,
but lately the occupy folks
is not just the standard.
You know,
we want these motherfuckers out there.
They're saying we can
all live together here.
We could grow our own shit.
We could,
you know,
we could form a community.
Just take this somewhere else.
That's what I keep hearing now
that you never used to hear before.
It's like everybody wants to
open up their own Waco comp out.
Everybody's ready to do it on their own.
Don't,
I don't mean that in a bad none.
I mean that get,
you know what,
Waco could have been,
I don't know,
how can you even say that?
We'll wake up.
Could have been,
but the idea behind it to have
a community will not wake up.
Why is it always go bad man?
How come no cult leader could come along
and actually make a bad ass caught and
everybody's cool with each other.
You know,
all those people at Waco murdered yes.
Out of Delta.
Yes.
That was horrendous.
You know,
was it rules of engagement?
Is that the documentary,
the details,
it shows you the fucking tanks with flame
throwers shooting into these people's
houses.
They crushed people inside their houses,
ran over and with tanks.
Look that place on fire.
That's a fact.
I mean is you can't avoid that.
We've been watching all of these crimes
taking place right in front of us,
all our lives.
Man.
I mean,
2000 election was stolen right in front
of our eyes and we didn't do anything.
And that's,
you know,
that's,
that's been,
uh,
you know,
I carry a lot of rage over the 35
years I've been doing this too.
But one of my biggest anger is if,
if you don't only listen to him,
to me 30 years ago,
this might not happen.
If you'd listened to Iran Contra people,
if you'd listen to,
uh,
you know,
all of the protest movements,
it nine 11,
if you'll listen to two,
2003 invasion of nobody,
there's this country never mustered the
will to call the crimes out when they
saw him cause they were
there for everybody to see.
And now we're all kind of go,
oh well yeah of course of that happened.
And of course that happened and it's
amazing how this is all predicted by the
founding fathers.
You know,
they,
they knew that everything was going to
get slippery and things is going to get
weird.
The fact that Benjamin Franklin Franklin
was the one who said he who chooses
security over liberty deserves neither.
They,
they did understand.
It's amazing that they figured it out.
But then if you go back,
especially,
you know,
I'm a big fan of Tom Jefferson who said,
you need a revolution.
Every generation,
you're damn right you
to share everything up.
Start over again and you know,
can we just Rodney king
this motherfucker is,
can we just all get along?
Why can't we all just
get along and how good.
How about these concert running the world?
Just get their shit together
without us having to know what,
you don't rise up,
can't you guys evolve?
They're going to have to die off.
Right?
The older ones are going
to have to die off.
They're just way too set in their ways.
The people that were willing to call
Waco and actually have that happen,
they didn't understand the impact of the
media because it hadn't really become
apparent yet.
No,
they didn't know.
They thought they were going to get
away with business as usual because they
come from a long career of doing that
and that's just how to get shit done.
They didn't think that there was going
to be a video camera that was going to
take film footage of it and
making it into a documentary,
explain everything and show it in slow
motion in great detail is that it never
been done before,
but it's done and you want to see it once.
You know.
That's actually a good point for the way
media and all this gear has been useful
in the occupy movement around the world.
I mean the anonymous is out
there kicking ass right now,
you know,
and uh,
and and so this,
this is kind of a dimension
which I think is fucking movie.
It was,
I was,
oh yes,
it's a movie.
I mean this is a great
action film right now.
So a lot of crazy shit going down.
I mean,
this is v for Vendetta
on the World News Desk.
I,
I analyze like 200 stories a day.
150 stories a day.
And we s that that's how we bring
you the news from all over the world.
He's really good stories.
But you know,
I'm,
I'm watching some of the shit happening.
I'm going pass the fucking popcorn.
I mean it's right.
It's like I can't believe some of
the crazy stuff I'm seeing right now.
Where's it all going to end?
Does it,
is it,
is there a real abi,
you've been really good at
predicting a lot of shit,
man.
You,
you predicted like pretty much every
single big economic event that's happened.
You,
you were on that before you
were right with Peter Schiff.
You were on that,
you were predicting that stuff
like way back in the day.
What do you see now when
you looking at it now,
what do you,
where do you see it end?
What's your prediction for how it ends?
Okay.
We're are rather comes to a
balance again where we are,
right,
right
now,
where we are right now is like,
um,
the mega and to climax
at the end of act two.
Okay.
Um,
uh,
the global economy is imploding right now.
Europe is dead,
and there's 1.4 Quillian quadrillion
dollars in derivatives out there that are
imploding because money,
like I said,
like I said in the movie,
that's exactly what I,
that's exactly the point I was on it.
This,
Whoa,
this is spooky.
Anyway,
money,
you can't,
it has no power.
Money only has power because
of energy and resources.
Okay?
And you can print an
infinite amount of money,
but we live on a finite planet and we're
running out of all the stuff that makes
that money,
have any power.
The money itself has no power.
And that's the adjustment that's,
that's civilization is collapsing.
There are 6 billion
people living here now,
only because of cheap energy.
And our population has gone straight
like that since the discovery of oil.
And it always goes like
that and then crashes.
And that's,
we're on the cusp of the crash right now.
You see,
you think we're at a cost of,
not of,
not just of a economical labs,
but a biological disaster thing.
Um,
what does,
I mean,
how are you going to get
rid of that many people?
Well,
uh,
wow.
Uh,
Gee,
you can let,
let all the radiation,
how to Focus Shima.
You can let all the oil out of the,
the Gulf or you can let a
billions of tons of methane.
There's now being released from the,
uh,
Tundra and Arctic Siberia.
Uh,
it's a catastrophic event for,
uh,
to a tipping point.
We've destroyed the environment as well.
That's going to kill a lot of people,
but there are 10 calories of hydrocarbon
energy and every calorie of food
consumed in the industrialized world,
the energy's going away.
And,
and the,
the top soil used to grow
food on is nothing but dust.
It's a sponge on,
on which they pour chemicals
made from oil and natural gas.
So People gonna Starve to death.
Holy Shit.
So it should have never got
this crazy in the first place.
We got way ahead of ourselves.
Technology got far enough ahead that we
could support gigantic groups of people
and we sorta like bought a car on credit.
I'm going to mess with your mind.
Please do.
I want to stand by the
people that do this.
The people that run the infinite
growth monetary paradigm system,
which to identify now I would say would
be the owners of the Federal Reserve,
the Bank of international
settlements in the city of London.
Let's start there.
Uh,
they've known that this outcome was
coming for a long time and are there at
their engineering and they
are making money from this.
Now the sick bastards are
deliberately letting things crash.
So they've engineered it,
they're profiting from it.
And then when it crashes,
what happens then if,
if,
I mean do,
does,
does it crash to a point where money is
useless and we start all over again or
it crashes to the point where we have
a thermal nuclear war that we're on the
cusp of right now over an invasion
of Iran for bullshit reasons.
A regime change in Syria,
which will bring in,
uh,
China immediately on a rand side
and a thermo nuclear conflict.
We could blow ourselves to smithereens.
And why are we doing that?
Why are we even thinking about doing that?
Um,
the parable of the
Scorpion and the turtle.
Okay.
Oh,
Jesus ain't that one.
I use it all the time.
Oh,
you're not?
Okay.
There's scorpions.
They cannot,
that's all they know how to do,
make money on the way up,
make money on the way down.
And this is pure evil because they
know what the outcome of this is.
They know that the outcome of their
actions would be either through climate
change to kill all life on this planet,
which is
well underway.
We're having a massive,
uh,
mass extinctions now,
run it economically into the ground,
polluted,
uh,
blow everything up
there doing all of that.
Yeah.
And for those who weren't aware of the
parable of the Scorpion and the toads,
the Scorpion asked the toad to
give them right across the water.
And the toad says,
I can't do that.
You'll sting me and kill me.
He goes,
why would I do that?
if I did that,
we would both drown.
So he goes,
okay.
And he gives him a ride,
and in the middle of the water,
the Scorpion stings him
and he starts to die.
And he says,
what the fuck?
And the Scorpion says,
it's in my nature.
I'm a Scorpion,
doesn't Scorpion dying that awesome.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
And that's the point of this parable.
You know,
it's ridiculous,
but it is what's going down,
right?
I mean,
no one thinks that this can go on forever.
Do they think that they
could just ride the,
the,
the asteroid before impact and die like
right before everything falls apart?
They're like 80 90 they're really not
going to make it to 2020 or whenever it is
there on that backs there.
Well,
it's supposed to be 2012
according to the Mayans,
but they couldn't even predict
their own demise was silly boys,
those silly people.
There's a lot of properties that
are winding up coincidentally.
And I,
you know,
I'm not saying I described
or that I'm a detective.
Well,
you know,
I think it's really fascinating that
to think that there could have been
alternate paths for intelligence.
You know,
the,
the path that Western civilization went
on with our interpretation of reality
and our construction methods and
all the different things that,
the way that we have expressed our tech,
our intelligence that
it could very well be.
And it's been proven to be in
Egypt and in the Mayans and the,
there was a,
there was an incredibly brilliant
society that operated very,
very much different than ours and
amazing different way to think while one
group,
part of the world was
thinking about something else.
They were studying constellations and
building these amazing stone structures
that really are,
are mind boggling.
And then when they find out that there's
thousands of them still undiscovered in
Mexico and South America,
that they're just the,
the,
the trees grew over them.
But there was a,
a great culture down
there and amazing culture,
completely alien to what exists right now.
And they operated on
different operating system.
I mean,
as you were saying that I was
having visions of first nations,
uh,
native Americans having really essentially
perfected their religion in that they
lived in a,
in a very balanced way
with their environment.
And,
but see that's a different
operating system.
It's like a different
vibration inside completely.
Um,
it's,
I don't know if you've ever done any
psychedelics or anything like that,
but it's kind of what you're going
to like a DMT trip or something,
right?
You know,
you see other dimensions and you become
so much more aware of other realities
and other truths.
And really what I think
what's happening now as,
as the old,
the infant paradigm is dying.
It's obviously dying.
I mean,
anybody who can't see the collapse of
human industrial civilization now needs to
be Darwinian late.
Deselected I mean,
so how do we get through this?
Do we get through this without
a die off or it has to be,
there has to be a die off.
I think that the way we get through this,
first of all is to realize
that there's no way,
uh,
in other words,
for all 7 billion of us,
um,
uh,
so we've got to cut off the rest
of the world and build up a fence.
No,
not,
not that either.
What you have to do is form
your own communities of,
of,
of people who have the same consciousness.
And you can do it in a big city.
Um,
where I live in western on the county,
it's just rife with that
or were like one of the,
one of the test beds for that.
So there's a Lotta a lot of hippie pussy.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's very important.
If you're going to have
some sort of a cult,
you got to have hot hippie pussy.
Yeah.
You know,
if you're going to start your own
civilization out in the woods,
can't do it.
We just do
that.
Shit's going to get boring.
And,
and there really is a lot to be
said for being very in touch with,
uh,
with nature and the rhythms of the
planet because once you become aware of
themselves,
they're very essential and,
and they're very,
um,
you know,
once you really start to plug into and
connect with some of the life that goes
on,
but most people in the world
don't have any clue about that.
Yeah.
It would be nice if we could all like
break off into like minded groups of
really nice people.
She would guarantee that your community
would just be really fucking cool.
You know,
no ego issues.
Everybody's had a few mushroom trips,
you know,
you know people like to do yoga.
They don't fuck with you.
They don't tell you that your music sucks.
Right.
[inaudible] it's so
difficult to get that though.
We were so many human beings.
Now,
when you fly over cities,
do you,
do you ever look out in amazement at
what a crazy structure like Los Angeles
really,
truly is?
You see the lights like when you
flew in here just flying at night?
No,
I,
we,
we drove.
Okay.
But,
uh,
I have flown into La.
It's ridiculous.
100 million times and
you're flying at night.
Very rarely flying at night,
but I did recently and flying in,
you see it,
you're like,
how is this not science fiction?
How has this not some crazy
blade runner fucking movie?
Just the way it looks,
you know,
flying into this giant grid of
artificial light motherboard.
It's amazing.
Yeah,
it's,
it's uh,
it's so,
it's,
so,
it's such a thing that
we take for granted.
You remember my friend Larry,
Larry had this house in
the Hollywood hills and a,
you would look out at night
and I never realized like,
why is it what you want to live in the
Hollywood hills and fucking pollutions up
there.
It's Shitty.
What fucking vision that view is the
view of the Los Angeles skyline at night.
Like it doesn't look good that day and
the day just looking down at like gray
shit pollution.
But at nighttime you're seeing
this crazy electronic tron grid.
Yes.
You know,
I mean it's really amazing.
It's,
we don't,
we don't see it because we're
down in it and a part of it,
but what a bizarre thing we've created.
Uh,
well,
you know,
part of that is it is also,
it's unnatural.
Yeah.
In other words,
that those collections
of lights,
definitely d shouldn't be here in southern
California because there's no water
here.
You know,
we also have a theory that it's bad for
our consciousness to have these things
at night because we not
allowed to see the stars.
Then we're not able to see the stars.
I think that's not good for people.
I think people,
I think a couple stars in the sky,
those are two abstracts.
You know the moon like,
oh there's my friend,
the moon I used to him,
the,
the image of the starry
nights in the BRASSICA.
When you're driving on the highway and
you just pull over the car and you open
the door and look up and go,
Holy Shit,
get out of the car,
get out of the car and look at this.
And you lie on the hood of your fucking
car for hours just staring up at the
Goddamn Milky Way.
But we don't get to see that.
We don't get to see that because we
want to keep everything lit up at night.
And because of that,
you,
you don't get that humility,
that realization that you
are in front of the infinite,
but you're experiencing and impossible
vision can have incredible beauty
connected.
And we've started,
we're feist it for streetlights,
for street lights.
We've sacrificed the most
incredible thing you could ever see.
And very few people ever get to see it.
And it's right above your head.
You don't get to see it.
You just don't,
you don't get to see it
for what it really is.
Story.
Uh,
uh,
it's amazing from John Dunn,
it was,
it was some early Christian Mancha,
uh,
a story about a guy who
was riding around on,
on,
on an ass all day,
a donkey looking for a donkey.
In other words,
it's like I'm trying to find God,
I'm trying to find God
and you're swimming in it,
but you're just not aware of it.
Um,
and it's that shift in consciousness.
We know we've got 7 billion
people on the planet now,
so not everybody's gonna get to do this.
This is where stuff gets really hairy.
This isn't every,
someone says something like that.
Yeah,
we're going to have to kill him,
you know,
and they want to die.
You know,
I don't want to kill anybody,
but death is inevitable.
Right.
But that's a lot.
That's a big number though.
I'm so,
it's so many people.
Do you believe in the Georgia Guidestones
is you believe that she was willing to
be like 500 million on the whole planet?
I believe that there is a
balance that can be achieved.
That's probably much greater than that.
If,
if mankind were live with permaculture,
we need more than $500 million
to fight off the animals.
I don't think we're going to get
to choose what the number's gonna.
Yeah,
I think the way we are
right now with the animals,
and it's very rare that
an animal attacks you.
I think this is the perfect place to be.
They can suck my deck.
All right.
They're all animals.
I'm on team people.
If we're just out there dominated to
the point where we don't have to worry
about them eating our children,
you know right there.
I think that's good because
this is a rare point in history.
People have sort of forgotten
that at one point in time,
just 50,000 years ago,
fucking blink of the eye.
Everywhere you went,
you could have gotten eaten.
You know,
everywhere you went,
you just animal wild animals everywhere.
50,000 years ago there
was fucking saber tooth.
Tigers are still there,
but there's,
there was always a balanced
humans rose to a population of,
uh,
two or 3 million stayed there
for a long estimated 5 million.
But it was stable more than,
well,
more than a thousand years at like
a billion people on the planet.
Wow.
It was,
you know,
but even this,
we were still overusing resources.
We were still chopping down all the
forests in Europe because all of the sea,
all of these,
all the colonial expansion was to
find more resources to consume.
We've reached the end of the planet,
you know,
there's no more places to go
discover to get more stuff.
So how do you stop people from breeding?
Because kids are awesome.
I love having kids.
It's like one of my
favorite things in life.
Is that the part of the problem?
I mean it can't be,
it can't be a one or two people.
I mean that you make the real
problem is a lack of resources.
Right?
The real problem.
Isn't it possible that there could be
some sort of a scientific discovery,
some something,
something that changes the
game as far as the way we can,
you know,
we can harness energy that
could possibly pull us in a,
in a more positive direction than
a complete and total collapse.
No.
Like some sort of a skin.
No,
nothing.
It's impossible
Dan.
No,
we're fucked.
Period.
Well,
there they are now.
Um,
you should have a tee shirt and
sell it on your website though,
by the way.
Since we're far.
Fuck yeah,
that would be great.
I have to think about what
to put on the backside.
There are upsides.
1 billion internal combustion
powered vehicles on the planet today.
1 billion.
Oh my God.
They all run on oil.
Okay.
And it took untold tens of thousands
of gallons of oil to make the vehicle.
You got to mind your,
you got to melt it.
You got a formula that paints oil,
plastic is oil,
blah,
blah.
So it took all the oil to make that.
So even if some new
technology appeared today,
you couldn't plug it into any internal
combustion powered vehicle and make it
work.
There's seven gallons
of oil and every tire.
Yeah.
How much,
how many gallons of oil
are there an electric cars?
Uh,
it depends on how big the car is.
I mean,
you know,
there's,
must be a lot though,
right?
Yeah.
I mean
is it's impossible to make
a car without using oil.
Yeah.
Impossible.
And even an electric car,
an electric car,
all you also have to worry about
conflict minerals that are powering your
batteries.
Electricity is not an energy source.
Electricity has to be generated.
How do you generate it?
By burning oil,
by burning coal,
by burning natural gas
or a nuclear reactor.
Jesus Christ.
Okay,
so electricity is no ads.
It still has to be generated and most
of our electricity in the U S is natural
gas and coal dictated to electricity and
once we got addicted to electricity and
then we multiplied like rats,
electricity is the lifeblood of
human industrial civilization.
The refrigerator on it
keeps the TV running.
It keeps credit card circulating.
It keeps you charged.
No electricity,
no economy.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
What a,
what a mess.
I mean it had that big blackout down
down here down to San Diego and Whoa,
whoa.
That was a bucket of cold water in
the face because that was real panic.
That was a multistate.
Those are going to do in the summer,
right?
Yeah.
Those are going to be coming and
eventually they're going to be permanent.
The power won't be coming back on again.
Isn't there a way to keep the power on,
dude,
come on.
I like refrigerated food.
I like TV.
Has gotta be a way out of that now help
us help those that want to be helped and
in the movie,
I'll have to live in the woods.
No,
no.
Well good.
Stay out of the woods.
In the movie,
I told the story about campers
being attacked by a bear.
Yes.
Okay.
Now,
if,
if you're in a camp and a
big bear attacks to camp,
you do not have to be
faster than the bear.
You only have to be faster
than the slowest camper period.
That's the lesson for everybody
here who becomes aware of collapse.
The slow campers,
the zombies,
as we call them,
are going to be out there
zombies until the last minute.
You know when,
when nothing is working anymore and
people are starving to death and they're
going to go and say,
well,
Gee,
I don't understand.
This is going to come back any second.
The faster campers,
the ones worthy of Darwinian selection.
Ha.
There are tens of millions of us around
the world already moving local food
production first and foremost,
start growing food wherever you are
right now and at and then building
communities and disengaging
from that paradigm.
So those are the people
who are going to make it,
you know,
uh,
and,
and some areas in some regions won't.
But let's see,
I get to see this all over the
world as a result of collapse.
I got do you have to be somewhere
where you're not going to need a car?
Does that an issue?
And eventually we're going to run an oil,
right?
Yeah.
Close.
Well,
no,
there'll always be oil in the ground.
I mean,
gasoline.
No,
I mean like when you think,
when do you think it will be an issue
where you won't be able to get gas?
Is that,
is that something you foresee?
It's an issue in this country right now.
We've had massive fuel shortages,
diesel shortages that have paralyzed us.
He's on the upper Midwest.
Canada.
Yeah.
And it's happening all
over the world right now.
You don't see it.
We have,
we're bringing out the
stories on collapse net,
Johannesburg,
South Africa,
gas station shutdown,
India,
Pakistan falling apart because
they can't get the oil.
Um,
so that's a problem.
It's going to get worse
and worse and worse.
It won't be like turning a switch.
You have oil one day and your gas one day,
Dan,
no gas.
The next day it becomes harder to get,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
Why is gas cheaper though right now
than it was like say three years ago?
That's a result also of the fact
that the economy is much slower.
It's 96% correlation between
greenhouse gas emission and GDP growth.
You don't grow the economy without
burning oil and natural gas.
Wow.
So,
so there's less demand now.
but when,
when Bush was leaving office though,
how'd they get away with jacking
the gas through the fucking roof?
Because it was almost like it was,
I almost heard like the
rolling stones plane,
who,
who like playing in the back
or why they were doing it.
It seemed like,
like,
you know,
they were,
they were going out in a blaze of glory.
He's the chief Francis Ford Coppola movie.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
at the end of it,
it was like they jacked it up to
$5 a gallon and everybody's like,
what the fuck?
Well,
people were like,
couldn't drive themselves to work.
You get to be a real panic.
That was a direct product there,
but I mean it wasn't George Bush,
Dick Cheney or a Hank Paulson or somebody
like that flipping a switch saying,
okay,
we're going to put gas at five bucks.
No,
it was a super heated economy.
We were growing then at the end of 2007
we were at and so the faster you grow,
the more energy you consume again,
but you reach a point as a result of peak
oil where you need more cheap oil than
you can find.
You've eaten all the low hanging fruit,
you found all the chief oil.
It's not inexhaustible.
Deep water horizons a result of us
being desperate to go out and get oil.
It's more and more expensive to get.
So the economy got so hot that the oil
prices spike because that was what demand
was doing at the time.
There was some minor stuff,
what Spec,
but it's fundamentally peak
oil and one 47 a barrel oils.
What shut,
shut us down in 2008 and we're,
we're just about to hit another place
right now with oil at a hundred,
hundred and five that's going to shut
everything down because people are so much
more broke than they were in 2008.
Uh,
and we're looking at a
possible attack on Iran.
We're looking at Saudi Arabia,
possibly collapsing a
racks now in civil war.
Just a week after we
pulled our troops out.
Isn't that insane?
Yeah.
Oh,
do you s is getting bitch slapped
around the world right now?
The a thing is insane.
I mean,
they,
they took a day,
they fell apart
immediately.
Like from the get go.
Actually on the same day that
the last the US troops left Iraq,
uh,
nor ya'll Maliki had a,
had a,
uh,
delegation fly to Syria to Damascus
to meet with a resident Al Assad,
because the US is trying to overthrow
Assad cause he's an ally of Iran.
And,
and uh,
I'll moloka who was a Shiite
was starting to side with Syria.
So the u s and Israel had been
very intent on attacking Iran,
which is a stupid suicidal move.
I mean,
it'll,
it'll kill all of us because
the world can't do without oil.
And that'll shut down
in the Gulf in China.
We'll bag.
It's ugly.
So what's the motivation for this?
What's the motivation to invade Iran oil?
To control the oil
and,
and because Iran is
truly a regional power,
uh,
that can threaten us western
control of the region.
But what's happening now as
the Western economies fail,
right?
Europe is toast and,
and,
and our,
our economy is in the shitter and
getting much worse all the time.
China and a w has been growing faster,
but China's now starting to fall apart.
But China is,
is,
is more of a,
uh,
an economic powerhouse than we are now.
So the people that have the oil will
go to those who can pay more for it.
China,
see,
when I look at us invading Iran,
it w w what freaks me out is it,
that seems like that's a real country.
Not that Iraq isn't a real country,
but it was run by a dictator.
It was run by a guy who was in
arguably completely up and we put them
in power.
He was an evil man.
He had evil children.
He just,
it was a fucking mass.
And then you,
okay,
we're in Afghanistan.
Well,
sort of a crazy situation in Afghanistan,
but there's a bunch of warlords running
the country and there's really only one
city.
It's cobble.
And it's a really unusual place.
You know,
it's like,
it's almost like there
is no government anywhere
and 80 80 or 90% of the world's opium.
And then all of a sudden
you talk about Iran,
you're like,
okay,
I ran as a real country.
Okay,
now you're,
you're dealing with a spirit of power.
You hit it right on the head.
Yeah.
This is a,
this is like we've stepped out of the,
okay,
we're just going after,
you know,
Banana Republic fucked up countries
that are run by crazy dudes and uh,
you know,
who have no power,
who are obviously humiliated
by us just a decade earlier.
You want to know the biggest
difference between Iran and Iraq.
Iran has had those same
borders since the time of,
of,
of Xerxes.
2000 years BC.
Okay.
That's been around its borders.
The borders of Iraq were drawn by Winston
Churchill with a pen or a pencil in
1921 after the end of
World War One and Iraq was,
was Iran is all Shia Muslim.
It's all homogeneous people.
Iraq is Sony's,
she is Kurds.
Uh,
you know,
they've got some Hashimite d and so
Iraq really shouldn't be a country.
Nature wouldn't have made it a country.
It was politically drawn that way.
And that's a big weakness for a
rock and a big strength for Iran.
And I think people sort of felt
something in,
in that way.
Like when we entered our rockets,
like,
yeah,
it's,
it's a fucked up place already.
It's really a good idea
to get rid of this guy.
No matter what you think about going Iraq.
It's like we know that this guy is crazy.
We know that if he really
does have a nuclear power,
we are fucked.
And of course,
Saddam Hussein had absolutely nothing
to do with nine 11 he had no weapons of
mass destruction.
He had no chemical agents.
And yet that's the same shit bloody
Barack Obama's trying to stuff down our
throats right now with Emeran.
Exactly.
And that's the button that Ron Paul
hits and that's the bullshit button.
I have a friend Dmitri Orloff,
he's Russian.
He survived the collapsed
and he's a writer.
Brilliant guy,
good friend.
He calls it the Aha moment.
It's the moment when in in
the old Soviet Union went,
everybody went,
Aha,
it's collapsed.
It's not working.
It's not credible.
Nobody believes it.
And Ron Paul is bringing that Aha moment,
you know,
like the emperor's new clothes.
When everybody in this country real,
it looks at every other sane
person in this country and says,
Jesus Christ,
this is all corrupt,
crooked.
We're not an,
all of a sudden we all see it.
Do you think another country is going
to get some sort of a nuclear power and
it's going to become an issue?
Do you think that's what's
going to happen to us?
No.
I mean that is the only
argument whatsoever about
suppressing other nations.
The only argument that it's like,
yeah,
yeah we got nuclear power,
but nobody else can have
it cause it's fucked up.
We used it once.
We feel real bad about it,
but we don't trust you with it.
I mean the idea
that you would want to stop all these
bad guys from creating nuclear power and
nuclear,
not nuclear power rather,
but nuclear weapons is something,
it's a consideration if you,
you're dealing with a really
volatile country in the first place.
I think our biggest concern now is not
some other nation getting cause it,
it's enormously expensive and energy
intensive to enrich uranium and,
and to make the warheads.
Believe me,
that's what I come from.
It's a background that I come
from when I had the clearance,
when I was living with my parents.
Um,
so I don't think we need to worry about
anybody learning how to do it or making
new.
What we've got is,
uh,
is hundreds of thousands of nuclear
that are already out that it's already
there.
We've got an,
there's a,
so we shouldn't be worried about Iran.
We should be worried about the shit
that was missing in the Soviet Union.
We just had,
we just put up a story on collapsed
that it was from a Japanese paper,
a
maximally remember,
but it was a good Japanese paper that
there's like 700 pounds of enriched
uranium that are missing from Fukushima.
Wow.
This stuff is swimming all
over the world right now.
So enriched uranium,
if you refresh my memory,
it is a,
was it enriched your eye product anyway?
Enriched uranium is like,
that's the stuff that they,
the,
the issues with a weapons
and Gulf War syndrome,
right?
No,
that's the same.
Pleated,
you're depleted uranium.
That's different and enriched uranium is,
is,
is uranium nuclear weapons
grade that you process with,
with heavy water was centrifuges with
in various ways to concentrate the atoms
of a,
it's either you to 35 or two
to 38 that give you the energy,
but it's,
it's like packing the punch to enrich it,
uh,
to make it fissile so that in a reactor,
when you pull the radio,
it'll create the heat because
all a nuclear reactor really is,
is a boiling water pot.
Albert Einstein,
look,
look at the first nuclear reactor.
He said it's a hell of
a way to boil water.
And that's where all the energy comes
from out of every nuclear plant.
It's just boiling water and steam.
Wow.
Yeah.
Most people don't even know.
They just know that there's a nuclear
reactor and they figure somehow or another
they get that into an
electricity line or something.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
the idea behind it is when
you look at it that way,
it's like,
wow,
that's pretty crazy.
Primitive.
Yeah.
What,
uh,
what a nutty fucking animal.
Human beings splitting
atoms for our own power.
And when the,
you know,
when they shut off or they,
get hit by a tsunami,
well,
here's the catch.
As collapse proceeds,
as,
as it gets worse as nations,
you know,
we're seeing sovereign debt.
Government's going bankrupt.
Tepco is going bankrupt.
Japan's going to nationalize it,
but Japan's got a bigger
debt than anybody else,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
I as collapse proceeds are our
ability to deal with Fukushima,
like events is going to diminish their
450 nuclear reactors in the world that
are running.
And if we don't shut them
down and collapse proceeds,
they're going to kill everything anyway.
How the fuck did we get
this screwed up so quickly?
Pretty Stupid,
Huh?
It's amazing.
It's amazing what an impact.
Just the last few hundred years
humans have had on the earth.
You know,
think about how innocuous we were for
the first million years of our existence
and the last couple of hundred years.
We just like a firecracker with a long
fuse that that last couple hundred years
was energy.
That's when we discovered the
energy's amazing coal oil is,
well,
why can't we see what we're doing?
I mean,
what,
what?
What kind of a weird thing are people
where they have such an amazing ability to
control their environment and to
influence their environment and we can't,
for whatever reason,
we can't feel what we're
doing bad to the environment.
It's almost like we have much more power
and much more ability than we have the
natural ability to perceive
the impact of this power.
That's the,
it's almost like,
yeah,
the disconnect.
That's that's,
that's what happened.
It's what it is.
Right.
When when the devil or whoever it was
wrote that into genesis one saying God
saying,
I give you dominion over this earth.
No,
see we are not,
God is in a mad scramble to figure it out.
Is that what it is?
I mean,
do you think that the way humans have to
evolve at an incredibly rapid pace like
sociologically or consciously to test it,
try to catch up with the technology
that's evolving around us?
It's almost like this
mad scramble is in place.
It almost has to be in place.
Just to keep up with where we are.
Technology is going.
I call that I gave a speech in a grass
valley that's up on the collapse,
that website,
the speech was called the
birth of post petroleum human.
And I coined a line in that,
uh,
I said,
we,
the people of the posts of
the new consciousness will
live in the spaces between
the ones and the Zeros
of Cartesian tyranny.
Oh,
that's pretty bad ass
where they can't get us.
That should be on a hallmark card,
you know,
and,
but,
but that's what this is,
you know,
this is,
this is like Cartesian
tyranny is like somebody's,
uh,
somebody's hitting the crack pipe,
you know,
just two seconds before they
die and they weigh eight pounds.
You know,
uh,
it's,
it's insane because it's supreme,
supremely arrogant.
Uh,
in other words,
one's,
and zero's can't measure heart and soul,
but music does,
fighting does.
And there's no,
that's not a one in zero thing.
It's,
it's something that
exists outside of that,
of those measurements and those controls.
Um,
and that's really what I think the occupy
movement is really exemplifying really
well.
So they feel victimized by ones and Zeros
in the manipulation and corruption of
the system that manages the ones and
Zeros and they're screaming out from the
visceral part of their
there from the mind,
from the instinct that's telling them this
is a fucking mess.
So when that woman says,
or when they say,
what are you occupying?
She says everything.
That's it.
Yeah.
When I was saying that the occupy people
are sorta like white blood cells and
they're just gathering around illness
and they don't even know what they're
going to do with it,
but they're,
they're gathering around
all the six spots.
There was a reason why.
And I got,
I got deeply involved in
that when I saw the violence.
And I've been an activist
a long time and I know,
I know a lot of veterans in the
La Special Forces and seals.
When I saw Oakland and when I saw
that all the unforgivable violence,
I was a good scar in the city.
I was,
I was sick.
I was as sick as I was when I saw
the Rodney King beating happened.
You know,
I was just sick to my heart,
but so were many of us.
And once you,
Mark Thomas did his thing,
she Mars has been a
guest on my radio show.
I love what he's way cool.
He's,
he,
he's having a hard time
dealing with a celebrity.
I say get used to it,
you know.
Uh,
uh,
but there were so many of us at so many
levels who stepped up because we were so
totally offended by that.
Um,
but occupy was threatening and the reason
occupies threatened and there was a
homeland security coordinated
the shut down of all the cities.
We had that on collapsing there.
Uh,
we threatened them.
The tent was so,
it's such a powerful symbol because
you've never seen a fucking mortgage on a
tent,
have you?
Yeah.
Right.
It's freedom.
That's the symbol.
And in the space that was created in,
in,
in my spirituality is it's very
important to create an hold,
a sacred space.
You know,
where the magic can happen.
And the occupy spaces,
there was such magic happening.
People were connecting and people were
waking up to each other and the learning
curve was going self.
Yeah.
Okay.
Listen to me.
And people were just figuring shit out.
One of the first things that,
uh,
Nyp Dee took out a Ducati park was the
library they had to get and they threw
all the books away and all
of my books were in there.
Yeah.
They took them right to a dumpster and
disposed of them because people would
just be in the library the entire
time the light people were coming.
People were unplugging from the Matrix.
So,
but why would they get rid
of the library just to,
because they were using it.
They were hanging out there like why
would they close the library and through
all the books away,
why did Hitler burned
the books really mean.
So they're,
they're,
they're worried that the,
that's where they're going to get all
their information from this library or
what their phrase,
it just a place to hang out.
They're trying to eliminate,
well,
what gay sex this is.
You know,
it's a big science that,
you know,
in mass psychology,
when you reach a certain
percentage of the people,
7% solution of whatever it is,
all of a sudden everybody
starts getting it.
That's what they were afraid of.
Um,
so they close the library,
they didn't close it.
They,
they,
they throw the books away.
They did the equivalent
of burning the books.
They disposed of them.
Wow.
That's because there were
a couple thousand bucks and
then anybody could really
rationalize that being a good idea.
That's amazing.
It's amazing.
Like,
you know,
and that's the other thing about
this NBA thing drives me crazy.
Yeah.
Or Nda I national defense authorization
act where they're proposing that they
can just arrest people.
They don't have to have a warrant.
They just have to have a,
uh,
an idea that somehow or another you
were a threat to America and they can
indefinitely suspend you and they
won't do it because they're good guys.
Don't worry.
It's just,
just in case.
But no,
you can't have just in case that's crazy.
It's crazy that it's gotten to the
point where anybody would even consider
saying yes,
do you know in Japan they can just arrest
you for 29 days and in those 29 days
they can torture you.
And most of the time they'll get people
to like say things or write things off
and then they'll,
uh,
prosecute them completely.
Wow.
It's amazing.
It's written in the u s constitution and
the bill of Rights Congress shall pass
no law.
Boom.
Freedom of speech.
Everything else.
Okay.
The bill of Rights Congress
has just passed a law that
violates the constitution
and the president wants it and he,
and he hasn't signed it because
we made bloody for rock.
Still hasn't signed as far as I can
tell you today is a huge outcry.
What is today?
The 25th,
27th,
seventh.
Yeah.
I don't even know what date is.
December 27th.
Yeah.
Okay.
So,
so he'd be,
he probably will.
Um,
has he expressed,
do you mean he said he
would veto it initially,
right?
A long time ago,
didn't they?
Yeah,
I don't think so.
Not that I've heard.
I,
I'm expecting him to sign it.
I had read somewhere that when
it was first being proposed to,
people weren't worried if it got through
the Senate because the president said
he would veto it.
Do you think it's possible
the president lies so,
so shocking.
It's just so shocking that they would
literally change what America is.
The whole idea of America is land of the
free home of the brave with liberty and
justice for all.
That was like the founding
principles of this great experiment,
liberty and justice,
and those words are so fucking important
because people don't understand this.
They are.
This idea of security being more important
is absolutely fucking crazy because
guess what?
You're were pretty God damn secure.
You have,
you feel like,
do you feel bad?
Do you feel like they're the enemies all
around you and terrorism is everywhere
you look,
it's not.
It's not just a few isolated examples
and they're using those isolated examples
to fuck you and to control.
You complete that down.
Seven year old girls in the airport make
you stand where you're weenies hanging
in the x ray machine.
They listen.
I'm,
I'm all for them doing,
you know,
airport security the right way.
I think it's a good idea.
It's a smaller deal.
They've caught some people doing thumbs,
but have you give people
power over other people?
I've seen people at the airport and they
may be just had a bad day or maybe they
were tired or whatever,
but I've seen them talk to people and
they're kind of shitty dorm and real short
to him.
And I've seen the opposite.
I've seen people at the TSA that
are real friendly and real cool.
And whenever you have that possibility
that a human being's day and emotions and
that factors into how someone is,
is a interrogated or someone is a,
it is handled going through the airport,
that someone could just be in a
bad mood and be short and snippy,
then I'll send,
that shouldn't be even in the equation.
That shouldn't be something that people
have to deal with when it comes to
security.
None of that stuff should
be in the equation anyway.
It should.
If,
if at anything,
it should be something nice and simple,
you know,
just that's conditioning.
No,
that's,
that's training,
that's getting you used to
being fucked with and so,
and it's so terrifying to,
to think that it's possible that there's
people out there that would allow
things to happen just to
tighten down security.
They would allow things that they
knew could possibly be taking place.
Let it happen now way once it does,
we'll tighten up this and this pass
immediately and then we'll just stick that
right in the back door and no one's,
I'm going to say a word,
you know,
nice businesses and nice government
contracts for people who are the,
you know,
the money gets laundered
through all the guys.
I mean it's,
it's sick.
The whole thing is the world
is governed by organized crime.
And if you think about a man,
can you point to any government anywhere
in the world that you think is doing a
good job,
that it's people are going,
yeah,
my government's really taking care of
me now because they're all run by the
banks,
gangsters,
Dick Cheney's the most
obvious gangster of all time.
Right?
We see the most obvious.
Well that's aside from getting
to the owners of the Fed,
the Bank of international settlements,
city of London,
finding out who those
financial powers that be,
Dick Dick,
those people at the
top of the food chains.
That's yeah.
And,
and as a shadow government,
we're going to find out more and
more about who they are as as things
deteriorate.
But Dick Dick Cheney is,
is far,
far and away the most evil senior
manager I have ever seen in my life.
That's kind of what my book
crossing the rubicons about,
along with a lot of other things.
But yeah,
he was a gangster.
I mean that guy shot his friend in
the face and his friend apologized,
you know,
that's his gangster as you get.
He was so terrifying.
A guy who made a living as the head of
a company that fixes shit after we blow
it up and then he gets it off and blow
shit up and then makes a fuck load of
money fixing it.
He killed 3,200 Americans.
And I say it in my book crossing the
Rubicon proves that Dick Cheney was the
mastermind and executed September
11th I'll take it to court,
the books in the Harvard Business Library.
So you believe that he actually engineered
it and it's not that they allowed
nine hello man,
heaven.
He commanded it and he did this to,
in order to get people excited about going
to war with Iraq or and have whatever
power we wanted and he is
fully aware of peak oil.
Iraq has the second largest
oil reserves on the planet.
So the only way to do that
was to allow planes or no,
he,
you're,
you're saying that he didn't even know.
He didn't allow it,
that he was a part of engineering it,
that he was a party.
Like he,
he literally said,
this is what we're going to do.
We're going to take some planes and we're
going to fly one of these buildings to
do.
People fly those planes.
They trust people to fly
those plans where they were,
those planes were flown by remote control,
remote control.
Again,
like I come from an air force family
that the tech,
what do you think all these
drones are flying around.
That's okay.
And that technology has been,
has been extent with
commercial airliners and in uh,
uh,
modern avionics for quite some time now.
Do you,
are you in the school that believes
that the buildings were also rigged to
implode?
All right.
Um,
I'm schizophrenia on that.
Okay.
Because I don't believe the planes
because the buildings to crash.
But what I have said throughout
the course of my career,
I finished right.
And Rubicon and o four was that I wouldn't
touch it because you couldn't prove
it in court.
The book that I wrote is
legally admissible in court.
There's a chain of evidence.
There's no chain of
evidence with the buildings.
You can't prove it in court.
And um,
I'm,
I'm still that good cop on the street.
I'd like to see somebody
ass go to jail for this.
So I went,
when I built,
in my case,
I built it from the framework
of can I get this into court?
You can't get building
collapse into Corcoran's.
There's no chain of custody
on the evidence from the
day of September 11th until
now.
Well,
I would wonder how you would possibly
prove it unless you built something just
like it and had the same
thing happened to it.
How could you really prove it?
That's the mistake initially specked.
I mean if you,
if something happened like that,
which is an unexpected event and
it caused the building to collapse,
it's nobody anticipated.
I mean that obviously there
was some engineering involved
in the construction of
those,
those buildings.
I'm like serious engineering.
Well obviously that
engineering wasn't up to par,
wasn't what it should've been.
Shouldn't there be some sort of a
lawsuit about that and we shouldn't,
shouldn't people be freaking out like,
hey,
how come you guys built this thing to
take an airplane hit and it can't take a
fucking airplane?
That's assuming that the,
that,
that the court system is honest too,
which I don't.
Right,
but again,
bill
dispute,
is there any other way to prove that a
plane hitting a building wouldn't take
it?
It's,
that's what's called in
the intelligence business.
That's,
that's called a red herring.
That's called an issue of the answer to
which takes you completely away from the
fact that I proved without
arguing building collapse
that the u s government did
execute the attacks of nine 11
what was the number one thing,
if you could,
if you could explain it.
There's a lot of people that would never
believe that anybody in the position of
government would ever do
any similar like that.
Anything similar to that,
especially anyone who was at the head of
a position of power in United States of
America,
the greatest country in the world.
So what does a number of for
one piece of evidence,
right?
This was a,
this was a piece of work that I did.
Rubicon is the,
I think the second or
third largest selling book,
about nine 11 really?
It's been a red all over the US
government can admit that I exist.
That's a separate story.
We'll get there later,
but my original work led me to,
I come from an air force family.
My father was a decorated aviator.
He was a in the 74th fighter interceptors
squadron in Maine during the Korean
War.
Waiting for the Russians
to come over the pole.
He was a radar intercept officer.
So I grew up being familiar with
norad and scrambled procedures and,
and,
and how it worked when
the attacks took place.
I saw the second plane hit,
said something's totally wrong.
That could never have happened.
That probably would have been
shot down a long time ago.
That that's what it was set up for.
But on the day,
how well,
how much time was,
it wasn't less than an hour
between the two planes,
a 48 minutes,
something like that.
Um,
but on,
on,
on the day of September 11th,
well,
you backtrack a little bit.
In May of 2001,
George Bush gave control of all war
game exercises in the country to Dick
Cheney.
Never been heard of before.
He also good norad scrambled procedures
were rewritten before the attacks of
nine 11.
But on the day of September,
the 11th,
I discovered,
and I have the,
uh,
the evidence in the book,
including an on the record email from an
air force major don areas at first air
force in Tyndall air force base.
And,
uh,
there were war gaming
exercises that were scheduled.
Now normally the northeast
air defense sector,
uh,
Angie Air National Guard pilots.
Um,
there's like,
you know,
50,
60 planes available in
all the states and needs.
Uh,
uh,
but there were war game exercise is the
Dick Cheney has scheduled that sent like
80% of the fighters from northeast
air defense sector to Alaska,
Canada and Greenland for war game
exercises on the day of September 11th,
a vigilant Guardian,
vigilant warrior,
northern.
They're all in the book and I
have the records of all of them.
Who made that call?
Dick Cheney.
Dick Cheney made the,
okay,
so now you have no fighters.
But then there was one war game exercise,
uh,
vigilant Guardian,
I believe it was that injected 24 false
radar blips onto the screens of the
northeast air defense sector
as the hijackings took place.
Now picture you're an air traffic
controller looking at your screen,
right?
You got to hijack alert,
boom.
And then you got this war game exercise
and you cannot pick the High Jack Out of
the 24 false blips and now you've only
got eight fighters left in the north at
northeast air defense sector.
They have to fly in pairs.
You got to have a wing man.
How traumatic.
Distinct.
So you couldn't,
I'm sorry.
Yeah.
So that's how I piece it together.
How it was done.
The planes were easily
flown by remote control.
I believe in New York City,
the remote control was operated out
of WTC seven which is why they had to
destroy WTC seven
well they had already had remote
control planes in the 60s fifties yeah.
But how would you explain
like the stewardess,
how would you explain
all the people on it?
Cause I mean I doubt like if,
if the stewards were like getting the
plane ready and they open up the cockpit
and Teddy Ruxpin was
sitting there to be like,
Hey,
what the way you do it is the pilot's
no longer have control of the plane.
That's right.
The pilots are in the plane.
They started to take off and then
they switch it off by remote control,
the thing by computer
and then they're fucked.
That these people are good for uh,
for a couple of decades were proposing
that was part of operation Northwoods.
They're proposing doing that to blow
up a jet airliner and blame it on the
Cubans.
They were going to say a whole bunch of
people died and they were just going to
relocate people
and then going back to my family history,
my mother worked in the
most secret section of,
of a army security agency.
The Japanese codes.
We had broken the Japanese Coats and
Roosevelt knew the Japanese were going to
attack and let it happen.
I was dating a girl who was
working in the White House is a,
I dated her a long time ago and she,
she worked,
she had something to do with a navy
intelligence or something like that.
I forget what it was,
but she entered something into a computer.
She uses some sort of a code word
that she wasn't supposed to use.
She brought Chai,
typed in little green men under
some sort of a data search.
And uh,
all these people came to
her and they sat her down.
They brought her to her room and
asked her what the fuck she was doing.
And while she was looking into
that and really spoke to her,
you know,
she did it as a joke.
I just thought you'd be silly.
You know,
and you know,
she was a young girl and they,
they're like,
the fuck do you think you're doing?
What are you looking for?
Hooker?
You know?
Yeah.
Terrifying.
Listen,
those guys run the world now.
It's,
it's amazing that it happened.
I mean it's,
it's amazing that,
you know,
you look back and Teddy Roosevelt,
you look back and Eisenhower and you know,
you,
you feel like that's a
real goddamn president.
That's the president.
That's the commander in chief looking
at the people with leadership and trying
to move us forward.
And that that was a guy.
I mean,
look when,
when,
when he left and he started talking
about the military industrial complex and
warning people about the dangers.
We,
could you imagine a
speech like that today?
No.
Everyone's bought and paid for.
No one would ever do that.
Did the United States of
America was mortally wounded on,
on November 22nd,
1963.
But the coup de Gras was administered
with the assassination of Martin Luther
King and Bobby Kennedy in
1968 and I was alive then.
And I have some,
uh,
some connections to Bobby Kennedy
as a result of my CIA stuff.
I was only a sophomore in high school,
but LAPD handled that.
And I was groomed by the same people
in Lapd who had done the Bobby Kennedy
thing.
And Sirhan Sirhan did
not shoot Bobby Kennedy.
I'm sorry.
He didn't,
that was a CIA hit from start to finish.
Jesus Christ.
So Sirhan Sirhan was just
what a set up a patsy.
He was over stones.
He was hip,
no program.
Uh,
they were very heavy into,
into research with LSD and,
and hypnosis,
uh,
to produce.
Uh,
so they talked him into it
somehow or another it was LSD.
Well,
there were that good at that.
not,
no,
he wasn't blow a fuse and
just stuck shooting everyday.
It's true psychological butchery,
you know,
uh,
there are records still
existing from the LAPD files.
I have some,
uh,
showing the kind of stuff.
He had lots of drawings and script,
so they planted ideas,
but they planted in him a hypnotic
trigger and that was a one.
What's the Manchurian candidate?
Exactly.
That's real.
They can really do.
Absolutely.
It's super effective.
They can just count on it and go
kill a guy was running for president,
you would think you wouldn't
want some more on that.
They murdered,
they murdered Paul Wellstone,
Senator Paul Wellstone,
and I did get a big thing on
that are from the wilderness.
Yeah.
They kill people all the time.
This train's death of Vince
foster is a great one.
Yeah.
So many of them.
I read that book a long time ago.
I don't remember too much of it,
but I do like having my jaw
halfway hanging off my face or half of it.
Like what the fuck they find this guy,
all his bloods missing got shot somewhere
else brought to this one spot guns
still in his hand,
which you never find when someone's self
administered gunshot wound that fucking
their hands.
Your hands go flying and the gun goes.
Yeah.
You don't have a fucking gun in your hand.
Yeah,
I'm sure he did.
Right.
Was that uh,
when,
when you saw that the Vince foster thing,
was that like a huge absolute bullshit?
Yeah.
But then again,
so many of us,
I don't want to think that
the Clinton administration,
we capable of something like that though.
We want to think that it's only the
evil Bush administration or both.
Dick Cheney,
he could do it.
Oh,
lot bill,
once you get his dick sucked.
I was,
I was burned on bill forever.
He's a drug dealer and
murder and son of a bitch.
Oh,
that's so scary.
Arkansas is the only state ever in
the history of the United States.
That was,
that had bearer bonds cause it was
laundering so much cocaine money.
Wow.
What is a bearer bonds bearer bonds.
In other words,
bonds.
They're bonds that you can walk into
any large bank in the world and redeem
right there for cash.
Whoa.
Oh my God.
So they just submit,
they let that be legals because they were
trying to get rid of all the cocaine.
Everybody was on the same side.
That's an amazing story for folks who,
there was a documentary on it.
Forget the documentary,
I believe it was an a and one of
those a and e shows Barry seal's,
Mena Arkansas.
Amazing story.
And that guy became the president and
we think he's like one of the best ones
ever.
You know,
everybody wants to bring them back.
This is a really funny story.
One of the,
one of the first stories,
I broke it from the wilderness and I,
and that was a newsletter I
had for eight and a half years.
We've,
uh,
our final coup was a breaking
the Pat Tillman cover up.
Uh,
my computer's got smashed
for that and I got poisoned.
But one of the early stories we broke,
Barry seal used to own a Beechcraft king
air 200 so really cool play turbocharge
two engines,
you know,
high t tail pressurized.
It's,
it's,
it's a Rolls Royce plan and,
and so I got a tip and the same plane
that Barry seal owned was George W.
Bush has playing Texas state
plane when he was governor.
He was using as governor
Barry Seal's airplane.
And I broke the story in AP,
came and picked it up from me.
Holy shaders pick it up.
Well,
didn't that happen
really recently as well?
Like a CIA jet that had been to Guantanamo
Bay at least twice crashed in Mexico
with four tons of cocaine in it.
We had a story.
Yes.
That was a true story,
right?
That that goes back to
Air America back to,
uh,
the old flying tigers in the
Chenaults and the Coleman Tang.
Nobody wants to believe this.
What you're saying right now.
Now anybody who believes it now,
everybody now,
but there's a lot of people out there,
especially folks that I'm like maybe in
their 50s that have had like a normal
job and you know,
go to barbecues on the weekends
and they'd go to church.
They don't ever want to like
think too far outside the box.
What you're saying is so
fucking far outside the box,
but there's a lot of
people that are going,
no,
no.
You're taking it too far.
He didn't,
they didn't cause nine one,
one proofs all there.
What do you think is the,
what's the number one
piece of proof to you that Dick
Cheney caused that to happen?
So the organs,
they were all under his control
because the fact it couldn't have been
coincidental,
it couldn't have been,
that may be someone knew that
he was doing these war games.
So they figured that's a time to attack
because you know when they had some
inside people in the army that he
knew of this and then they leaked the
information and they said,
well we'll get you another week.
Do you read against possible?
Did you just listen to what you were
explaining and how like not credible?
That sounded.
It sounds ridiculous,
but yeah,
I agree.
But I'm just giving you a what f because
I watch mission impossible five the
other night.
Oh my God.
Pretty bad ass up to the end,
but I'm willing to suspend disbelief,
you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
But I mean,
is it,
is it possible that,
that that happened or no,
no,
no way.
No.
Come on.
You had of the 19 hijackers,
uh,
I think we know that five had,
had,
had received training
at US military basis.
Uh,
Mohammed Odd Dot Gunter Annex
to Maxwell Air Force Base.
And I have all of that in there.
But hold on a second.
If you think that the planes
were taken over remote control,
do you think that people were,
the hijackers were actually
really on the planes and attack,
right?
The hijackers were on the planes,
but they weren't,
they didn't know or they didn't know.
There were 12 I call Patsy's who
were like sacrificial hijackers.
They were never meant to live anyway.
They were on the plains,
definitely planes were flown
by remote control because,
uh,
you know,
pilots like,
uh,
I'll,
how's me?
Or I'll meet our,
whoever was supposedly flying the,
the,
uh,
the plane of the seven into the Pentagon,
you know,
that's a,
that's a maneuver.
Like one of the most experienced
pilots in the world couldn't make,
and this was a guy who couldn't
get a multi-engine license.
He couldn't get an instrument rating.
He had no hours.
It's not possibly be,
none of those maneuvers could have
been performed by any of those people.
So,
uh,
and,
and I hold some question as to whether
Mohammed auto and several of the ones
that I and Michelle,
Chelsea Dusky and some
great work was done,
uh,
on the flight training,
by Daniel hop sicker.
I've seen early stuff hop sick,
did amazing work about the Venice Flying
School and Mohammed autos flying circus
and all real hard documentation.
So I wasn't alone with me
and Michelle Chester Dusky,
uh,
Dan hop sicker and Paul Thompson,
Thompson,
we,
we were the four guys who
really did 90% of the nine 11.
Enlighten me about the argument when
it comes to the physics of actually
following a plane.
That what I had read that it's
much more difficult to do,
like physically difficult to do what
they're doing by steering it than it is to
do it by remote.
Well control
what they were doing.
It's physically hard to do because of
the g force of the turn and everything.
Well,
and it's also the calculation that you
have to understand it when you're flying
a seven,
five,
seven,
six,
eight and you're coming out of
a turn on onto the north tower,
right?
You got to know what
the fuck you're doing.
You gotta be good at that Shit.
That's like a formula race
driver driving through a chicane,
holding the perfect line.
Yeah.
I was thinking that too.
Like what's the,
keep that fucking plane
from spinning upside down.
Now this asshole is spinning it
around in a circle like that.
Well he knows how to do that with a jet.
No,
a giant jumbo jet.
These guys couldn't fly.
They weren't licensed to
fly a regular old Cessna.
So how many people know about it?
All together.
If you had to guess,
if you said,
okay,
there's Dick Cheney and he's,
he's the guy that you perceive as being
the mastermind and then there's a bunch
of people also have to be in on it
because they have to rig these planes with
remote control capability
and they have to,
that's already there.
Order NATO to stand down.
You know,
they have to,
they have to do all these different
things that they did that day.
How many,
well,
it's compartmentalized intelligence.
Now remember I come from a spoke family.
So let's say you're making an atom bomb,
right?
So some guy in Oak Ridge,
Tennessee might be doing
something to enrich uranium.
Some guy someplace else might be making
part of a super hard steel casing to
contain the blast for one of the bombs.
Somebody else may be working on it.
Nobody knows what the
finished product looks like,
right?
That has to be a few at the top.
How many people do you think?
No,
I'm guessing a 30 40 50
that's terrifying.
It's terrifying that 40 or 50 people
would be willing to do that and that they
could all find each other
and form a gang and you know,
and,
and actually make something like this
happen and they just hang out at NASA all
the time.
Not Nasa or,
uh,
some Army Pentagon type place.
Now I'm soundstage.
Do you think that the thing that hit
the Pentagon was a jet or are you okay?
Was it a missile?
No,
it was,
it was an airplane.
It was an airport.
Okay.
Again,
I was a cop.
Right,
right.
And so what I was another
remote control airplane,
you believe?
No.
Yes,
yes,
definitely.
That's why I was able to
do something so crazy.
That was a 270 degree loop turn coming in.
What the engine cowlings
probably five feet off the deck.
A human pilot can't do that.
Really remote control can,
but here's
because they've had to be,
I'm sorry,
but they've had people actually
try to attempt that in uh,
uh,
in an aviation simulator and
they weren't able to do well.
Is it a physical issue on
understand what it is skilled?
You'd have to be just some bad
ass fucking race car driver,
motherfucker,
who knows how to get around
the Norberg ring in seven 19.
Right?
Is that what it is,
Liz?
Yes.
Uh,
and you must've practiced
that one turn 10,000 times,
right?
You practice moves and
Marshall Your sleep.
How often do you work a cotton before you,
you know?
Okay,
so the Pentagon sits in a bowl
when I was born in Washington DC.
I know it.
Okay.
And three 95 runs around the Pentagon
and you can look right down and you see
the whole Pentagon sitting down there.
It's like,
it's,
it's like,
uh,
sitting in the Roosevelt.
Okay.
Now,
um,
there were more than 400 witnesses
on I three 95 truck drivers,
cab drivers,
soccer moms,
you name it.
They all saw an airplane hit the
Pentagon and they would testify in court.
That's,
that's what they saw.
So regardless of what anybody thinks,
I'm not going to argue.
The point is,
the fact is,
is to try the case in court
and to Hang Dick Cheney,
which I can do without
going down that side alley.
It's not important to me.
Uh,
but I do think,
uh,
a jet plane hit the Pentagon.
Well,
they released that footage,
but it was like stop action was only a
few frames and you can't really clearly
make out what the hell it is.
Yeah.
Why do you think they did that?
Why don't they release like
some clear footage in the,
you don't want people
using it for propaganda?
I mean,
in the intelligence business,
um,
there's a program called
cointelpro and many other,
uh,
programs that,
have been used and developed by CIA in
Army intelligence on the creation of
false legends and false stories.
And um,
one of the biggest deals in
the intelligence trade is to,
uh,
do a dangle dangle a in,
let's say I'm a spy.
A dangle would be like a five foot 10
woman right out of my ultimate sexual
fantasy,
you know,
blah,
blah.
That's a dangle.
But sometimes a dangled comes
in the form of information.
Sometimes a dangle comes in the form of
attempting lead that looks like it's got
to really take you somewhere.
Now,
disinformation,
in order to be effective
has to be 90% true.
Otherwise you won't swallow it.
You won't buy it.
So there's a poison pill that they put in,
you swallow the 10% poison pill,
and then if you ever get enough traction,
they activate the poison and kill you.
So I do believe a plane
hit the Pentagon and,
and I,
and what we saw,
we never saw a jetliner
hit in any of those films.
Okay.
I think that was bait to,
you know,
to see if that action got enough traction.
Then at some point they would come up
and actually show you the video of a
jetliner hitting and all of a sudden
everything else you've bought into as a
result is discredited.
He looks preposterous.
Exactly.
Yeah.
I've always thought that was fascinating.
Like when you read someone's
stories and you know,
you read something like that guy,
a behold a pale horse guy,
William Cooper's Braille Cooper.
Well,
what was that guy's deal?
Um,
because he would,
he was one of those guys,
let me just say before you even tell me,
he was one of those guys that I
would read his stuff and I'll go,
well that makes sense.
That makes sense.
Oh,
he's fucking crazy.
Exactly.
It was like that was the,
the,
the exact progression.
And so that made me think,
well what if this guy is
like working for them?
Like making everything else look retarded
by coming up with this one idea that
he tosses in about bases on the moon
where they're processing fucking compound
race tires for the corvette team.
You know what I mean?
To me it's like,
yeah,
he was three.
He would say something
like that and you're like,
the fuck is this guy talking about,
you know,
there are lots of people like that and
this is why I've walked a completely
different path because I had to walk
a path of complete credibility for 35
years.
So
you think there's people that are embedded
in that path that are there just to
say stupid shit like this credit things?
Yes.
But I also think there are some people
who who are feel moved to tell the truth
cause they're outraged.
That's you.
Yes.
But those people would,
would all say,
I'll also say something that they
know tells to the powers that be,
that they aren't a threat.
Well what's really funny is,
oh the lot of you guys,
and I don't want to lump anybody
into a category and then I'm,
I'm certainly not putting you in with
anybody else because I love your work,
but a lot of you guys
think that it's not you,
not you,
but people along those lines
or calling out the government.
They think that there are people out
there that are shills like other guys that
are successful,
like their competition.
Oh that motherfucker.
He's a,
he's a CIA.
He's an operative.
Well I wouldn't say CIA,
but there are definite
people out here for sure.
Absolutely right.
How many,
when you see like a guy on
TV and you see him talking,
like how,
how much time do you give
him before you start?
Like wondering if this guy is a plant
while and you see any sort of a leader in
any,
any sort of a movement,
how much time when you watch them,
how much time do you like?
Well,
my rule of thumb is,
is that they wouldn't be on TV
unless they were already controlled.
Anyway,
that's just the real
simple way to look at it.
You don't,
you don't get the airtime.
See,
I'm invisible to,
to the,
to the u s government.
I made it,
uh,
the video that's had some good
play called say my fucking name.
It's up on you.
I saw that.
That's crazy.
You know,
and it's fascinating.
I've done all his shit.
Right.
And it sounded a bit like a jilted lover.
Thank you.
But if,
you know what I mean?
Like it was a check that,
but I was also everybody
in the rolling stones,
we are pissed off.
Yeah,
I'm sure.
Yeah.
I mean,
it makes sense because I've
been saying all this shit and,
and like the US government spent a
State Department has spent $3 million
refuting every other
nine 11 theory out there,
but not yours.
She couldn't mention my name.
So does it feel like they don't have to
address you because you don't have as
much mainstream exposure is say you
know any of these other guys that you,
you know,
you know what I mean?
Is that what it is?
Wait a minute.
No,
no.
Uh,
I was in this really successful
movie called collapse.
It's been seen all over the world.
That's obviously [inaudible]
copies of that APP.
But you're obviously not on
the cspan shows or CNN shows.
You're not being interviewed all the time.
I've been blacklisted.
Right.
But why is that?
If all is he just cause they can't
control you just say 100% true.
They can't shut me down.
I've left a record of 3 million words in,
in Rubicon,
there's a thousand footnotes.
So no matter how many books,
this cells,
no matter how many people watch,
collapse,
they'll keep you off those other shows.
So there's absolutely,
and that plays out real well with
native American spirituality,
which was something that,
that,
uh,
that I've come to understand
and really appreciate it.
I'm deeper into it.
And,
uh,
there's different kinds of medicine
attributed to different kinds of animals.
Bear medicine.
Fox medicine has been
very powerful for me.
Is that what is one that
makes your penis hard?
Is that tiger medicine that could,
didn't know that's a squab medicine.
Squamish.
So what do you mean by like
bear medicine and Fox medicine?
It's very important.
I've had a couple of very
powerful encounters with foxes,
Fox medicine in native American
spirituality and makes you invisible.
In other words,
I am invisible to the powers that
do you work for the government?
Because this is what's going on here.
No,
no,
I'm just kidding.
Yeah,
I know.
But you're saying crazy stuff now you're
saying crazy stuffs about Fox being
invisible.
And so if Pete,
if somebody thought that you
were a disinformation agent,
they would say,
oh,
here's the evidence.
He says all this brilliant shit.
And then he starts talking
about foxes being invisible.
No,
I didn't say Fox is invisible.
I'm invisible.
Oh.
And I'm invisible
to mainstream media.
Right.
They all read me that they've all read.
They all know who I am.
They just can't say my name.
And that made me mad.
ButW I made that tape it because I was
so pissed off that everything was falling
apart and nobody was talking about
how criminal and how fucked up.
This wasn't a whole generation of
people are talking about it though,
don't you think?
I mean at this point a lot
of people were talking,
but if they say my name,
it's game over because then they
have to see the body of work.
But,
but what you,
so you saying that all these people that
are in any position of power that are,
you know,
saying the sky is falling,
it's all falling apart,
but whatever you do don't
talk about like a rubric.
Don't give him the mic.
Why did they,
why,
why?
It doesn't make any sense.
You seem like the perfect
person to talk about this stuff,
but someone has to be an expert.
I'm good at.
But then I'm gonna
proved that CNN,
that ABC,
that all the corporate owned media
is absolutely criminally corrupt and
complicit and all the economic criminality
that's been taking place and covering
up all these other crimes.
Every major media outlet in this country
trades it's shares on Wall Street and
they're all part of the
same economic paradigm.
And they can't afford to see me.
And it's not just me.
I mean all the people who did peak oil,
who'd,
who've done the work on,
you know,
they see me because I give
credit to everybody else.
They got to see all this other
body of work that they've ignored.
But
so if the cop talked to you
about any of this stuff,
then it opens up the flood gates,
the CIA selling drugs and all this.
So they're like,
shut the fuck up.
Michael Roberts not coming on the show.
Exactly.
You know,
someone intern comes up again.
There's a kind,
he's name's Michael Rupert.
He's ringing,
articulate.
He's like,
he's The star of that movie.
Collapse.
Get the fuck out of here.
Get Out of my office.
No,
no,
he can't get on the tonight show.
Well,
when at what shows have you been on?
Who has let you on Bill
Maher ever had yon?
No,
no.
You gotta be on that Shit.
You know,
I would love it if he had the balls.
I don't think he has the ball.
He has the balls.
That's crazy.
You don't think Bill Maher,
he didn't build.
Marta's can give a fuck.
He's got the balls.
Hbo Rice.
Just pay checks.
Yeah,
but you think that
they're going to really,
he says,
well as feature versus more
shit on that show time.
Yeah.
And,
and that's like a,
one of my other [inaudible] their favorite
whips out there.
Amy Goodman,
democracy too late.
She,
she,
she talks about all
these great issues that,
that,
that don't change anything.
She's like a gatekeeper.
And she syndicated by Rupert Murdoch.
Do you think she works for the government?
Well,
I,
let's,
let's rephrase that.
I think she knows who butters their bread.
So it's fucked.
But the Internet is the only hope.
Right.
But now that there's
stuff like Sopa right.
Is it is the stop online piracy act.
A lot of people who are paranoid
about this see this as a back door to
passively,
you know,
this is the beginning of
the regulating the internet.
Trust me,
I got a chapter called on promise,
Piero Mis software,
uh,
in,
in that book,
which talks about some of the
stuff that government can do.
The government can now anything
that they want to do right now.
Sopa doesn't scare me enough cause sopas
just kind of legalizing something that
I are,
that we know they're already doing anyway.
Right.
I mean we've been under severe hacking,
uh,
at,
at collapsed net and we got a great
team of it specialists and we're,
we're talking coordinated d dos,
you know,
new servers,
bloom,
boom,
boom.
Getting into our emails,
shutting us out of this shutting down.
They even go so far as to change like
the number of visitors we have on the
website to make it look like
nobody's looking at our website.
They can go backwards.
It's stupid.
Um,
they're doing all that now.
They've done it to occupy me.
And of course we see
anonymous doing that back.
So that happens.
But so I'm not so much worried about Sopa
because I know the bathrooms are going
to do that.
So that to you is just like sort of
confirming something that has already been
in play.
It means nothing.
Nothing's changed.
Well,
it was already bought and sold.
They're going to go to another degree
of difficulty or another level of
intensity with that.
But,
but the detention,
uh,
provisions in the NDA totally
violate habeas corpus.
Magna Carta,
US Constitution.
That's fundamental.
And,
and if that bill gets signed,
the United States of
America no longer exists.
Nicholas a thing to,
things have gotten so bad that they
think they need to pass that look.
Right.
It's not that bad.
So you've got a few people protesting.
Yeah.
It's really,
you don't need to have the
military and the fucking streets.
All right.
It's really,
it's not that big a deal.
But what the problem is,
is they're looking at the next step.
They're saying this is unpredicted.
They never thought that
they would see this.
They never thought they would see
hundreds of thousands of people,
you know,
ranting in the streets,
chanting in the streets,
holding signs,
wandering around,
and then camping out like
what the fuck is going on?
So this is why they showed their hand.
But they have also been very aware,
Joe,
that there are,
uh,
50,
60 million hardcore unemployed homeless
people and the number is growing.
They're aware that,
uh,
now,
it's a one in two of the people in this
country can be classified under the
poverty line.
Half of the population,
one in every six Americans
is on food stamps.
People are starving,
they're freezing,
they've lost their jobs,
they've lost their money.
They've known this was
going to be coming too.
But I think there's
another reason for this,
uh,
with the planned attack on Iran is,
is so that
they can do a round up of Arab Americans
like they did with the Japanese right
after World War II and put them in camps.
Jesus Christ.
So you think that the ultimate goal is
to start locking giant groups of people
up in Fema camps?
No.
And this is where I did I disagree
strongly with some people.
Alex Jones.
Oh,
absolutely.
Yeah.
Uh,
it takes money to feed people.
You have to pay the guards,
you have to build the camps,
you have to put gasoline,
you have to heat for the people.
And human industrial civilization is
collapsing if you think to what the powers
that be,
the money people did during
the Great Depression,
they didn't put all the homeless,
starving and camps.
No,
they let them drag themselves across
the country from the Oklahoma Dust Bowl,
the California.
And if they starved along the way,
the government wasn't paying a penny.
It costs nothing.
It weeded out the population
and the strongest made it
to California to work for
slave wages.
That's the evil of the beast.
They will have camps,
you know,
for people like me or if there's major
civil unrest in some cities or something
like that,
but no longterm,
because the resources
don't exist to do that.
So the idea is this,
kill everybody.
Then let them starve.
Let Them Starve,
starve to death.
Let him catch disease or so in
turn them and then make them sick.
I wouldn't go that far.
No,
I mean,
uh,
I mean ultimately if they know
that that's what's got to go down,
why not just,
and everybody,
well that was Diana,
Jim Jones,
everybody.
Yeah,
no,
that,
that was a Nazi plan and that didn't work.
The fascism has become much
more sophisticated since then.
So what,
what,
what are the other options when
it's completely hit the fan?
What are the other options to get
rid of a giant group of people?
You let,
you let the cities go,
uh,
you let the people,
it's happening all over
the world right now.
And you think that's
unquestionably a plan.
Sure.
Who,
who,
who's planning to have all
these cities fall apart?
No.
Well,
the bankers,
again,
nobody plans for city x or citywide a
fall apart that way on a day just engineer
corruption into the systems
to the point where they,
and you believe it's engineered well,
is it just greed and it is a,
uh,
I mean that's what I'm confused about.
It collapses a fait accompli.
That's a simple matter
of what does that mean?
Well,
it's a done deal.
Au fait accompli limit of
what language is that French?
Why is it so cool when he's quote
something and we could just say,
well faith it is right.
That's a good way to get laid.
Sorry.
Um,
so the resource limitations govern.
Collapse,
right.
Okay.
6 billion people.
So because of the way society is set up,
there's no way all going to
collapse and wear out anyway.
We need a resource based society.
We can't have the derivatives,
we can't have this nonsense economy
and we can't have infinite growth.
But all the powers that be want to do
is make money on the way up and maximize
profit on the way down.
So they're just trying to money grab
right now and just as much as possible is
more profitable to destroy things now
than it is to save them in the NBA is
basically just like what we need.
We need to keep fucking peace in the
streets where were stealing money or scare
the people in the,
yes,
they have crazy laws.
We can just lock people up.
You know who's lagging me blow up though.
That's where it gets really ridiculous.
It at one point in time someone has
to realize that the structure of this,
uh,
this monarchy,
this,
uh,
this fucking king ship
that's taken over the world.
It only works if people were willing
to take up guns and only works if the
common folk are willing to
push around everybody else.
I mean,
that's the only way it
works out really work.
If everybody goes,
wait,
where's it?
Fuck you.
You know,
I mean,
you need the cops.
He knew me like a guy,
like a guy like you who
steps out and you know,
when you were a cop and you saw this
corruption and you step to what you were a
regular person instead of identifying
yourself with this organization that was
obviously sick,
you identified yourself with your morals
and your character and your upbringing
and you said,
fuck you.
The CIA selling trucks,
you know,
at some point in time doesn't,
I mean,
isn't that the real solution?
Is it everybody sort of
realizes that they can't do it?
No,
but this is like one of the coolest
things that's happened to me in,
in,
in 30 years.
That was cooler than Fox magic.
Yeah.
You know who killed Tupac,
don't you?
Yeah,
the cops did.
Yeah.
There's a you ever,
you ever see that man?
Do you want to talk about corruption?
Terrifying story.
Even joke around.
We can do that all night,
but yeah,
man,
part the Rampart division.
I was going to say this
is better than Fox magic.
I was like,
oh,
it's impossible.
Okay.
Fox Mask makes you invisible.
What could be better than that?
Yeah.
It's like one of the key.
If you could have a superpower,
what would you take?
If it sees two POCs needed?
Native American wisdom has
taught me that if I am the wind,
it does not matter if people see me.
It only matters that the Pete,
that the leaves blow.
When I,
when I go by,
oh,
that sounds tripping.
That sounds like again more shit.
You would tell the hippie chicks.
So anyway,
God,
you guys are going to beat me up bro.
He's quoted a bet Midler song on my
pocket the whole time he's been quoting to
bet Midler song.
Oh my God,
it's,
this has a big joke.
Well,
you remember when Herman
Cain started quoting Pokemon?
I was like this,
this might be it fake.
This guy might not be real.
Do you think Herman Cain was really,
was he just in a position as a spoiler?
I mean it was Herman Cain
was a hired sideshow.
Really?
I swear to God.
I know that sounds ridiculous.
I know it sounds ridiculous,
but when he started quoting Pokemon and
using the fucking grand theft auto tax
tax program,
I was like,
wait,
a may have to create all this drama
to make you believe that there is a
democracy at work out there.
So what do you think that was where
some due to just a super successful
businessman and they cooperate him.
They got ahold of him to the lecture.
He got some great business
deals to go through.
Everything he went through
and he's going to walk away.
He was never going to be
president to begin with.
It seems like he was
just fucking everybody.
Huh?
Anyway.
Can I tell you this thing?
And it's better than Fox magic.
Yes,
please.
Sorry,
fucking with me.
Here is a great podcast,
man.
I'm gonna join us.
Thank you very much.
The core of the coolest things
that happened to me was,
um,
after Oakland when Scott Olson got
shot in the head with a flight,
right.
Uh,
army veteran and I'm really close.
Don't know,
elaborate on that story.
It's a horrible story.
During the occupy Oakland,
uh,
demonstrations,
late at night,
um,
Scott Olson was one of several
guys that were out front and he's,
he was military veteran and the cops
were firing 40 millimeter flight,
right?
Projectiles out [inaudible] 79 bloopers.
I've shot.
Those are little grenade launchers.
They're kind of fun.
Uh,
and,
and uh,
somebody shot him in the head.
It was accidental.
Okay.
But after his skull was fractured
and he was on the ground,
you see the cops lobbying a cs canisters,
uh,
gas canisters right into
the group of people.
And there was so much brutality.
And this was after watching
the white shirts in New York,
you know,
and,
and Shamar Thomas hadn't come up yet.
I don't think he had yet.
Uh,
but we went to occupy
Santa Rosa and it was like,
uh,
which is the town close to where
I lived in a town of about,
uh,
we had the highest per capita
turnout in the country.
Uh,
so we had like 3000 people turn out,
but we were going to put up camps
and the chief of police had said,
we will use any means necessary
to tear down the camp.
Now what happened was I
went there and I said,
they're going to fuck these people.
I'm putting my body in front of them.
I took an oath and when I got there,
there were all these veterans,
there were Vietnam veterans and there
were Gulf one veterans and there was one
active duty guy and it was an army ranger,
special forces medic.
And we had all showed up there with all,
we all had the same idea.
We are going to get in front of the cops
so that when they start shooting the
gas,
they're going to hit us.
And if they want a beat on somebody,
let them beat on us because we know that
we can take that without throwing back
to Jesus Christ.
And this groundswell from
the veterans community,
Honorable Warriors,
the Shamar Thomas's you know what is
so sad and I've had a really close
connection over the years from
doing investigating murders,
have a lot of uh,
army special forces,
special OPS personnel.
Um,
for all these years we have had really
good men go off to war and never in my
war has lifetime has there
been an honorable war.
Vietnam wasn't,
none of it was honored.
It was all crooked bullshit.
But there are guys who went
out there who did the deed,
who put their lives on the line,
got their combat infantry badge,
whatever,
and didn't commit atrocities in really
horrible wars and came home and they've
never been able to shine like that.
And when Shamar Thomas did that Shamar
Thomas was speaking for everybody who'd
been to war in this country's military,
who served honorably,
who didn't commit atrocities
in wars that we all know,
we're totally fucked up,
fraudulent and light.
The,
the,
the best teacher,
the most powerful teacher I've ever had.
I gave a talk
at Portland State University right after
nine 11 became my video truth and lies
of nine 11.
And,
uh,
native Americans showed up,
knocked on my hotel room doors about
five foot four and his name was skip May,
hawk.
And,
uh,
what a presence,
you know,
have you ever looked a fighter in the eye?
And there's just some guys
got to look in the eye.
Sure.
Fuck most of them.
Yeah.
And,
and so here's this guy.
I look down here,
you know.
Hi,
I'm Scott May Huck,
I'm here to be your cameraman.
Second camera man tonight.
I didn't know he volunteered.
He showed up.
It turns out skip had served with a
hundred and first airborne and the
[inaudible] valley in 1968 some of
the bloodiest battles of the war,
uh,
the Asha was legendary.
Uh,
and skip was awarded the
Congressional Medal of honor,
the medal of honor.
Uh,
and he refused it because he
was fighting in an unjust war.
Wow.
And he fought beside Russell
means at wounded knee
and he showed up to be my camera man.
And he became a teacher for me.
And he was one of the,
the,
the Great Warrior teachers that I've had
who taught me about the power of honor
and why it's important to
fight in an honorable war,
not going to die.
You're honorable death or,
or you know,
to fight honorably,
but to fight in an honorable war.
That's what a warrior needs.
And,
and I think Shamar Thomas
really embodies that.
Um,
and he was just a snapshot.
He's not a fluke.
There's lots of Shamar
Thomas is out there.
Shamar Thomas is the guy who
yelled at in New York apartment.
There's no honors or you sleep at night.
Yeah.
Mara.
People probably don't know
what you're talking about,
but there's a video out
there of this guy who said,
well,
big dude,
and he's got all these metals on and
he's like pointing to the metals.
Like,
these are lies,
you know?
And he was like explaining to all the
shit that he been through and he was like,
this is not a war zone.
These are your people and how you sleep.
And I,
and it's really powerful.
There is no honor in this.
And they can't say nothing.
They just sit there and eat it.
Yeah.
You know,
and it's,
it's a crazy moment.
That's,
that's
the power of honor.
And that's been Mike,
Mike,
and again,
I'm not the only one who's done this.
There's a lot of us,
we're all standing up now because the
criminality and the bullshit in Washington
and Wall Street is just so out of control.
Is there a way to turn it around?
Is there a way to somehow under
the steer this back to the light,
is there a way to make this culture wake
up and snap itself out of it before we
hit the wall?
Well,
a lot of people are snapping out and
stepping out or waking up right now.
A lot of people are,
and it's happening in very big numbers.
Um,
I,
in terms of saving the system,
no,
we got to get Obama high.
That's what we got to do.
Got a kidnap him higher,
higher.
Can't say that.
You can't even say that
there's a guy yelling.
I was,
that was a total joke.
Here's the guy who's got tomorrow.
That's tomorrow.
Yeah.
He was a guest on my radio show.
Really cool dude.
If you get she choose to
get high with one person,
it wouldn't,
it would be Barack Obama.
You wouldn't want to sit down with that
guy and find out what the fuck is going
on.
I mean,
when you,
when you get really blasted
where you can't lie and just
start asking him questions like,
I don't think I'd want to know
what would come out really.
I think I'd be fascinated.
I would want to,
I wouldn't want to say first.
What's that?
You would choose him first.
Yeah.
Oh,
hush man.
For sure.
He's like so close to my age.
I,
I'm,
I'm fascinated.
You know,
I always looked at Lexi's
president guys as being these,
any of these old evil men with hearts of,
you know,
of,
of diamonds.
And you know,
they fucking of blood.
That's coal,
you know,
I mean just,
just evil and nasty,
evil people who have gotten to a position
where they can choose to start these
wars.
But then I look at a
guy like Barack Obama.
I was like,
well,
he was probably like close to my age
when I was 10 he was probably like 14 or
something like,
that's like,
that's real close.
Like that guy grew up really recently.
He grew up with the Internet.
He grabbed me,
know what's going on with him.
How was,
how were they able to do this to him?
You know,
how did I,
that's it.
That's incredible.
One of us.
Well he know he ain't me.
You know what I'm saying?
In my perception as a fool,
he's not one of us.
He's a,
this is a government of the banks by
the banks and for the banks and Barack
Obama's presidential decisions,
especially since 2008 all of the sea has
done was to make us pay for all of the
Wall Street crime he's,
they have,
they have taken all of that debt,
all the money.
They printed the derivatives and the bail
out shit and they put it on our backs.
And that's what's happening
around the world in Greece.
The banks now run the code.
There's a banker in charge of Greece,
there's a banker in charge of Italy and
Barack Obama has done the same thing to
us.
And all that debt that belonged to
Wall Street is now on our backs.
Have you seen the video where Barack Obama
says that he believes he's the fourth
best president?
Have you seen it?
Oh God,
no.
You see it in Brian.
Brian find it on Youtube and
watch it cause it's hilarious.
He talks about,
you know,
different presidents that
have accomplished more and
the only lists like three
that he thinks of accomplish
more than they have.
There was a guy named
Alexander soldier needs,
who was a Russian writer,
very great Russian writer.
He lived 30 years in a Gulag prison camp.
Right.
And,
and he came up with a great line.
He said,
men,
in order to do evil must first believe
that what they are doing is good.
Wow,
that's incredible.
So you convince yourself
that we're the elite,
where the rich we have the only way to
manage things we have to do to that and
they delude themselves.
That's,
that's the Fed,
uh,
stale nature of a democracy that has not
been ventilated and breathe and air it
out for a long time,
you know,
and die.
I don't want to save this system
at all as far as I'm concerned.
And especially what the
end of energy with W.
Dot.
The endo w with peak oil and collapsed,
the United States can't
possibly hold together anyway.
So when peak oil happens in gas becomes
extremely expensive and probably
impossible to get,
then what happens?
We often branch off into
little communities and make
our own medicine was solar
power.
I mean,
what are we gonna do with
those of us who were smart
enough to start moving in
that direction ahead of time?
Yes.
But peak oil has already happened and
there are in this country with all of the
tens and hundreds of millions of people
who are unemployed or below the poverty
line,
people who can't afford
gas at any price right now.
So it's going to slowly keep creeping.
Yeah.
And that really,
when we think about it,
the real big jump was the end
of the Bush administration,
which was only a few years ago.
That's nothing a blink of the eye,
you know?
Well,
they knew it was coming to think of how
bad it could be three years from now.
Thank you.
Well that's good because again,
we all wind claim here is
progress rather than perfection.
There's not not ready and then ready.
You know,
you're not in a binary state.
Do you subscribe?
No.
We talked about earlier,
but do you subscribe to the,
the Mayans ideas you think
they were on to something?
I'm amazed at the coincidence.
Yeah.
Amazing.
Right?
I think there is,
I mean,
everything else in this world
we look at now is a lie.
Okay,
come on.
It's a lie.
There's a recovery.
Uh,
we killed the Osama bin.
Ladin it's a lie around
was behind nine 11.
It's a lie,
you know,
Wall Street,
it's a lie.
Your pension fund,
it's a lie that,
okay,
so you know,
all that stuff just needs to be seen
what it is and disengage from it.
It's kinds of mass destruction.
It's codependent to want to
go in and fix that system.
It's picture somebody wanting to go to uh,
the Nazis in 1938 and saying,
okay,
let's have a campaign to organize the
teach the Nazis that the Jews are really
good people,
the smart people.
We're just saying,
I'm getting the fuck out of Europe.
The Jews,
smart Jews were getting,
you know,
getting out of the way the world knew
what was coming with that and it's,
and it's not mentally sound
to try and fix this system.
This,
this system needs to be redone.
Ron Paul's got a good end and the Fed
you got until you change the way money
works,
you change nothing.
That's the big start.
Then you gotta and fractional reserve
banking compound interest in Fiat
currency.
What is the,
what's the solution when you have to
do something to put something else in
place?
What are you doing bro?
Here's the,
uh,
Obama,
oh,
am I ready for that?
Where do I look here?
I have right,
right.
Straight ahead.
Well,
there is,
I'm not going to be a list of
accomplishments as you said yourself,
Steve.
Yeah.
I would put our legislative and foreign
policy accomplishments in our first two
years against any president,
uh,
with the possible exceptions or Johnson,
FDR and Lincoln.
But,
uh,
you know,
just in terms of what we've
gotten done in modern history.
Yeah.
You raped the world.
Congratulations.
Good job.
Way To go,
dude.
He got the Nobel prize after these and
then you sent 30,000 more people out to
Afghanistan with,
with,
with guns.
He's,
he's Hanks.
He's bloodier than chain Bush.
It's amazing.
It's amazing that he could
actually say that though.
What,
what,
what legislation?
Oh,
you mean you know the,
the ability to just start arresting
people for no fucking reason would it?
What is it exactly that got accomplished?
Did I miss something?
Yeah.
What,
what are these great
legislation of achievements?
Do you know what he's talking about and
know what the fuck could he be talking
about?
That's the Orwellian nature of
this absolute crap we see on the,
on the mainstream airways
horseshoe this whole time.
It's like some precedent thing like,
oh yeah,
what?
Nevermind what I'll tell you dude.
I don't know.
I don't know what the
fuck you just said Brian.
Nevermind.
That's okay.
Yeah,
he's a silly boy.
Um,
so you know all that stuff.
It just needs to stop.
So like I said,
you predicted a lot of shit.
You,
you,
you been at the firm,
I mean,
I forget when it was,
when you,
when you started predicting that our
society was slowly going to collapse.
It was like way before anybody
else was ever doing it.
That was in one was when I first started.
What do you think is going to be 99 point?
The end point is going to be,
is it going to be,
we find groups of people and we
hang out together and grow food?
No,
that does.
You know,
I'm probably more grateful for that
question Joe than any other one because
that's what we're fighting about now.
When we want to get Ron Paul elected,
that's what we're fighting about.
It stops when the people wake
up to the point and says,
this has got to stop.
Because if you can get a
guy like Ron Paul in office,
you think we can kind of smooth
everything out and still have cars.
He uh,
well,
oh,
we will still have cars.
Even if we have bio diesel run on,
or even if we have,
you know,
some of the criminal in the White House,
uh,
you know,
they're,
they're going to become harder to find,
but we're fighting to determine how far
this system is going to run everything
down before we put our foot down and say,
this has got to change.
That's what's gonna make the
difference because this system,
I wrote an essay called
Global Court some years ago,
and in it I said,
the way the system works,
infinite growth,
mergers and everything.
Now,
the last CFO of the last
corporation in the world,
Global Corp,
when the world is in total ruins,
when four or five,
6 billion people are dead,
when one guy has acquired all the ones
and Zeros of wealth and that company goes
bankrupt,
he's going to say,
hooray,
we did it.
That's where that ends
until and unless we stop it,
human beings stop it.
And the consciousness is
here that understands that
the infinite growth economic
paradigm will kill us in
order to make a profit.
How much time do we have?
Well,
if,
uh,
if there,
if there's an attack launched on Iran
within the next week or two B or before
the Iowa third,
excuse me,
the January 3rd,
I will caucuses and China
comes into backup Iran and
the Russians have said they
will back up a,
a nuclear weapons or exchange.
It could be over in two weeks.
Jesus fucking Christ.
I got shit to do.
Dude.
I have a new special to make,
I'm going to release
it like Louis C k look,
um,
this is very frightening stuff.
You think this is unavoidable?
You think that a nuclear
war with Iran is just,
no,
I don't.
And seeing very strong
signs that,
that uh,
the United States is getting bitch
slapped around the world right now.
Um,
since we,
since we killed 24 Pakistani troops,
I sat hilos killed 24 packs soldiers,
uh,
all of the supplies going into the NATO
forces in Afghanistan had been cut off
through Pakistan.
How ridiculous was the asking
for the drone back from my Iran?
Did that make you feel like it's a
work of fiction when you saw that?
Fubar it's just foobar it's just nuts.
Save and asked him to go on TV
and say that we asked for it back.
They told Obama to do that.
It's almost like they're making him out
to be a buffoon and towards his last
couple of years,
this is your script.
This is what I want you to do.
I want you to go out there and
when they say about the the drone,
just say we asked for it back.
He's probably like,
what the fuck am I going to say?
It's like a sitcom actor.
It doesn't want to be humiliated.
Some shit line.
This is a bullshit line.
Expect it to be a lot more nonsensical
all the way from here on out.
And the only way to avoid this is to
have a guy like Ron Paul and office.
It's the only to avoid
going to war with Iran.
Know How do we avoid it?
Because the occupy movement
is demonstrating that you've
had 100,000 people out
in the streets of Moscow.
There's an occupy related occupy inspired
revolt in the village of Uconn in
southern China,
which has made,
made the Chinese communist
government backed down.
And it's,
again,
it's not communist versus capitalist.
It's all money in banks and
growth and all that stuff.
And,
and this is a growing wave of
consciousness that's magic.
And that's why there's a lot of days
when I walk around and lately and I see
things happen and I'm just giggling.
So you love this.
This is fun for you.
You,
well,
first of all,
you've been first.
First of all,
you've been predicting it for a long time.
So while it's happening you like,
see I fucking told you
there's a lot of that,
right?
But there's also,
you're happy to see the system fall apart.
Not because you want people to die,
but because it's a fucked up system that
doesn't work and it needs to dialing
anything that doesn't work.
Let me make it
very clear.
I'm doing everything I possibly
can to accelerate the breakdown.
If the United States government and and,
and the,
and the economy and the banking
system and everything else.
No,
under the Patriot Act,
are you allowed to say shit like that?
Like getting can't that could be,
could that be interpreted
as you're a threat?
Only God determines what I'm allowed to
say and nobody else has the right to do
that.
And isn't it supposed to be enemies?
Both foreign and domestic?
Yes.
Who forgot that?
How come everybody forgot that?
Well,
the foreign and domestic,
that's the beauty of,
of what Aki and all these
veterans showing up.
Captain Ray Lewis,
the Philadelphia police captain who showed
up in his uniform and got arrested at
Ducati.
There's W W we're stepping up by the
thousands all over the country and we're
making ourselves known
throughout the movement.
And what we're discovering is there's
lots of us out here and we are not going
to let this go down.
And if the,
uh,
detention provisions are passed
at NDA and they're employed,
you're going to see,
you're going to see massive breakdowns
because there's got to be soldiers in
this country that won't fight.
There's got to be cops that
will stand with the people.
Five county sheriffs in
northern California have
United and county sheriffs are
the most powerful dudes in the,
they can
tell the president to stay out of the
county legally and the president can't say
Jack about it.
Um,
isn't that changed as you,
they probably just
changed that with the NDA.
They probably just changed
that with something,
some sneaky bill they stuck
through and yet it doesn't matter.
Once they bring the military
and it's illegal to grow food.
You guys said to plant your own food.
Did you note that that one bill passed
that that makes it illegal to Predix?
Why isn't food?
Well,
no,
there are some laws that that restricts
some people's ability in some places to
grow food.
Yeah.
If a dude farts a lot,
you can't be grown
broccoli in your backyard,
but the real base or the FDA and so forth
to come in and say you can't drink raw
milk,
which is awesome.
I love raw mill Roman cause
delicious and they stopped that.
They used to get it at whole foods.
They don't have it anymore.
It's,
it's spotty around the country.
I'll have to go to the farm.
Um,
Senate bill s five 10 Sanibel.
That's five 10.
And what does it actually say?
What does the actual language,
it's pretty long.
It was not enacted.
It was not passed.
It wasn't know that there was a senator
from Montana who introduced an amendment
to that bill that removed
that clause from there.
Isn't that crazy?
Yeah.
What kind of an asshole
do you have to be seated?
I love to go out tomatoes.
I think we were just not enough.
You know,
we've already fixed all
the problems in the world.
It's concentrate on people growing food.
Yeah.
Think about all the shit that
we have problems with prison,
overpopulation,
war on drugs,
all the different issues
that we have to deal with.
Pollution of the environment.
And someone shows the contrary
on people grow fucking food.
But our whole civilization now is
predicated with the corporate control to
banking control on us
not being independent,
not being able to function outside of a
system that they control that the giant
agribusiness corporations,
Monsanto and Cargill control.
How scary is Monsanto Santos?
Crazy.
Terrifying.
Did you know that Monsanto was one of the
companies that was looking into buying
black water and black
water was believe that?
Do you believe that?
Yeah.
They can't tell like who
bought a controlling stake
and they couldn't tell if it
was like one of the people
that owns Monsanto cause it's,
you know,
there's a lot of crazy paperwork
you've got to go through.
But the idea that that was even thought
of that the country that could Jorg
accompany rather the controls,
food growth in hundreds of
countries and not hundreds,
but a lot of countries,
but not only does that,
but it's been shown that politically
they forced their GMO foods on these
countries that don't want it,
can't afford it.
They have suicides all over the
world where people can't keep up.
Farmers are committing suicide,
can't grow their own food again.
They can't reuse seeds.
They can't make their own seeds.
Okay,
so what's difficult to
get about the concept?
It's something like that
is just pure fucking evil.
That's what it is.
Exactly.
The fact that that's not stopped.
You know,
it's amazing.
They didn't want to talk about gay
marriage and a time like this and that.
It's even discussed.
You know that any of
this nonsense it gets,
well,
you know what?
What about the debt?
We got to push the debt back.
What the fuck about this?
What about everything?
Well,
what about the whole pile of it?
It's Goddamn ridiculous.
If design seeds to suicide
itself after one season,
I
was so scared.
But we've had some stories on collapsing
that recently that shows that the
Monsanto supposedly bulletproof
seeds are producing mutations,
which Monsanto can't control.
There was like one that
was just released on us.
Some,
some major news source was talking about
the connection between animals having
tumors and their meaning.
Some corn that Monsanto
genetically modified corn.
It's not for human consumption,
but it doesn't matter because you're
fucking feeding it to animals.
Those animals might get
eaten by people and you know,
you don't know what the fuck goes through.
You don't,
they don't know.
They don't know what the reaction is.
A human body eating 20 years
of genetically modified
beef because we haven't
done it yet,
but now get that around the world.
There are tens and hundreds of millions
of people moving to re localize to grow
organic food.
That's what I'm doing.
Um,
and to take control where we can.
And those are the faster campers.
Those are the ones who aren't
going to get eaten by the bear.
What is going to be the big difference
between after the collapse and now what
is going to be more most inconvenient
about after the collapse?
Are we going to have like crime issues?
We're going to have like roaming gangs.
That's going to be during
the collapse during the,
that's all.
That's all what's coming.
That's what's here now and
that's happening all over.
We had the bloody Reiland
riots all over England.
We had our MacArthur set on fire in Rome,
the Arab spring,
you know?
Right,
right.
But in general there's like,
you have a few things
that the like blipping up,
but if you look at the overall harmony
of the earth at any given moment,
most places are not in conflict,
right?
Most places are just people
going about their business,
trying to live their life.
What these spotted atrocities
popping up here and there.
You know,
if you look at it on a,
you know,
as a,
as an organism in conflict,
it's not in as much.
It's not like a hundred percent conflict,
eh,
direct correlation between
that and population density.
Big cities are not sustainable.
And when you see things like Egypt,
like the,
these,
these crazy beatings or they're doing
the protesters in Egypt now and you see
like this,
this battle to control Iraq,
do you think that that was engineered
that they knew that in a vacuum that you
know,
these puppet governments they put
in place would quickly fall apart?
No.
Well,
I really think the US government was a
cocky phlegm Boozell old cocky because we
built,
and I have this in Rubicon three mega
basis there that were meant to be
permanent installations.
And I mean some of the largest,
most expensive military basis ever built.
We built a,
uh,
an embassy compound
larger than Vatican City.
You know,
we're going to house like 8,000 people.
We plan to be there forever.
So is why we get now it's just too crazy.
This is the Roman Empire.
It's crumbling.
Jesus Christ.
This is the Roman Empire.
It's fall and the whole world can see
that the world starting to move much more
closely into alignment with China
and China is imploding also.
That's the other catch to this.
Uh,
and the same thing is
happening with money as,
as it is with,
with life and everything else is that
people are jumping to the next safest and
all they're doing is moving
up one deck on the titanic
to a deck that hasn't gone underwater yet
and hoping that their kids live to be,
to miss the next big wave that they get
to stay alive and die before it all the
shit hits the fan again.
I mean,
can it be held back?
Is it a wave?
There's a come and go there.
I just have to completely
flat line and then rebuild.
It won't be flat line across the board.
When the Roman empire collapsed,
there were some small towns
that survived as pockets,
you know,
of wisdom and you know,
we're,
some civilization was held for a while.
That's the way this is going to play.
There are going to be places
around the world that,
uh,
that by virtue of,
of climate there a orientation to
permaculture sustainable economies and the
skill sets they have that will
fare better than other regions.
Um,
I think basically the people in the cities
are fucked and if you stay in the big
city,
you're going to be fucked.
No one,
no food here.
It's only a three day food
supply in Los Angeles.
I graduated from Venice High School.
I went to Ucla,
you know,
and uh,
there's only a three day food supply in
the city and there's not enough fresh
water here.
We steal the water from
northern California.
Las Vegas shouldn't even exist
and Phoenix is going to go under,
I mean those cities,
right.
Love the story of the salt and sea.
This is one of my favorites.
I,
I've watched several documentaries,
read a bunch of things on and I've got
a whole coffee table book at home of
photos from the salt and sea.
That's an amazing story in and of itself.
And we just decided to get crazy and
create a civilization out there in the
middle of the desert where
they happened to Vegas easily.
Yeah.
Thanks sir.
Wow.
They're going to keep Vegas alive as long
as they can because this weekend it's
Brock Lesnar vs Alistair Overeem bitch.
Oh,
I mean you could live on stripper
milk for a couple of days extra,
I guess.
And you could kill small animals
with their heels and if you know,
use their heels off projectiles.
Listen,
there's all the squirrels.
There's going to be some bizarre Darwinian
evolution and adaptations is this
thing falls apart.
You're going to make it through how much,
how much longer do you think it's going
to be before everything it was easy is a
50 year processes at a hundred
year probably we going to see this,
am I going to be alive to see
this new of same has happened
much,
much faster than I thought it would.
Especially with the deterioration
in the quality of US government and,
and the legality or honorable
nature of the u s government and,
and the economic situation.
Um,
does it disturb you when you see Obama
and looking confident and talking about
his legacy as a president and disturb
you to see like this unaware mother
fucker?
Like what are you doing?
Why are you sitting there calm and,
and congratulatory,
you know about your administration and
the accomplishments that you've achieved?
Do you not see that the
fucking sky is falling?
Do you not see it?
Look at you sitting there.
You sit in there like a demure gentlemen.
I've been so calm and so accustomed
to being in front of the camera
was president.
I mean,
it's like everybody in
Washington does the same thing.
It's ridiculous.
You know those people.
That's why we're,
again,
Ron.
Paul is so important.
Solar power,
yes or no,
should we get solar power?
So if you can get it,
it won't solve all the world's problems
and we need to stop buying that trap
that we have to solve the problem for
the whole world before we take care of
ourselves.
We need to take care of ourselves.
Take our ourselves.
Put Your own oxygen mask on first.
Yeah.
It's not like we were
rushing out to fix Liberia.
Right.
You know,
we know how bad it is over there.
I know now about it is in Somalia.
We're not,
we're not running over there to fix that.
No.
We take care of ourselves here first.
And,
and those of us who
work to build community,
there's a great movement transition us.
There's transition into Su
and initiatives about 111,
I think all over the country now in
cities all over the country where where
people are forming communities,
they're growing food locally,
they're networking with each other,
they're working outside
of the economic system.
They're learning skills that they're
going to need and we're all going to need
at some point learn how to live with
less power and things like that.
And this movement is at,
we have a uh,
a directory on collapsed
at the light director,
absolutely free.
1600 hand picked entries and you go in
and you look around this directory and
you realize that all over the world
there's all kinds of people working really
hard and have been for quite
some time to prepare to transit,
to live outside of the infinite
growth paradigm after peak oil and,
and,
and it can be done,
but you have to do it in small groups.
But then you have to be worried about
being raided by a mad hordes of fucking
scoundrels and zombies.
Depends on the apocalypse.
Zombie Apocalypse Thrill,
right?
Most of the zombies,
I don't think we'll ever get out of the
big cities because so many people are so
out of touch.
So the big cities or
just be like die offs,
giant die offs.
Just like there were for the Mayans.
Right.
The Mayans left the giant temple's behind
and when they discovered him hundreds
of years later,
they are covered in trees
and there are people who are,
have been putting a lot of
time into thinking about
how to defend what they have
if people come and try to take it.
So what do you think about the,
I guess it was the ATF saying that they
were going to stop people with medical
marijuana prescriptions
from buying new guns.
They weren't going to allow you if you
get a prescription for medical marijuana
to own a gun,
which is whole areas.
Yeah,
I mean I live in Sonoma county where,
which is a,
uh,
illegal grow county and I handle that.
Have to get a,
uh,
I have a letter because I had really bad,
I just,
my thumb socket was shattered.
I mean that the socket was an eight
pieces and that's where all the nerves in
the hand come together.
Oh Wow.
And that happened.
And a horse horseback riding accident.
And uh,
and I'm a horse one.
I've been a horseman a long time,
but uh,
so,
and,
and that works for me,
but I don't grow because I owned guns
and see that's a federal issue as opposed
to the state issue.
Um,
but you know,
all that stuff.
I think it's a matter of growing.
I think you're not even allowed
to have a license for it.
No,
no.
Is that what it is?
Okay.
They don't care.
So you can have a license.
You just can't grow.
Is that what it is?
Well,
or you know,
or feds wouldn't know that if
I was growing and owned guns,
which I obviously do,
you know,
then they would come on
some federal pretext,
you know?
But
how crazy is that that you could
have a prescription for Oxycontin,
which he can't grow a plant.
That's amazing.
You could,
you could have a gun and have
a prescription for oxies.
How absurd is it to make a plant that
God created illegal to begin with?
It's amazing.
Not only that one's killed nobody.
Yeah.
You know nobody,
I mean maybe some people who have had a
few wacky ideas while they were high and
it caused a few deaths.
But listen,
that's just people with wacky ideas.
You can't blame pot for that.
So it's like Bill Hicks joke about a guy,
young man and acid thought he could fly,
jumped off a building.
What a tragedy.
He goes,
what an idiot.
If he thought he could fly,
what did he test it off
on the ground first?
You know,
no one told him to jump
off the fucking Bruno.
I was
work and and and and,
and I've seen bad drugs,
but the worst drug or that
has ever been out there is,
is a angel dust.
I had to fight people on Angel Dust
and it was the most ridiculous.
It was stupid.
Buddy of mine got his finger bit
and often it was on angel dust.
He didn't even realize it
until the next morning.
They have special purpose fucking finger.
Yeah.
I'm the only guy in the history of
LAPD to have been bitten in the left
testicle.
Oh,
snap son.
Was it from the sham?
Wow Guy.
Did it burst it?
No.
Imagine if it was so,
it just really hurt real bad.
It was,
yeah,
it was a,
it was a little bitty five foot eight
guy on angel dust and I met him like God
on Angel Dusting.
Went for the balls and while
he was holding a 35 inch
color console TV set above
his head,
oh my God.
Five of us controlled him.
And we was strapped on a Gurney,
you know,
thick canvas wraps on a Gurney.
He broke the canvas strap over his leg,
gave himself a compound
fracture on my God,
and everybody went back to his leg and
I was at the head and he just went,
oh.
And he spit your balls.
Holy Shit.
You stop.
'Em Out is your ball okay?
That's fine.
Good for you.
Yeah.
You got to stop.
That tore down all these years
since I bite in your balls,
you got to stop.
My nickname was inspector clues.
Oh,
so you gotta go pride rules on that dude.
Holy Shit.
What's the most fucked up thing you
ever saw while you were working?
It was a cop
probably,
uh,
a homicide.
Uh,
I was a training officer.
I was two striper,
Pete p three here in La,
and I was at working in El car on a
Sunday and the south end of Wilshire,
I worked in the jungle.
Uh,
that's where I came up as a cop and it
was a homocide and the Ra unit had gone
there and opened the door.
And this guy had been dead for three days.
Every window in the house
closed to the heat was on to 90.
Oh my God.
And the inside of the windows
were covered with maggots and,
uh,
and,
and I was the first officer on the scene
and it was a Sunday and I had to sit
with this stinker for five hours.
Yeah,
I was the crime scene.
I had to protect the crime scene.
Okay.
So when you protect the crime scene,
do you have to be on top of the body?
But how close do you see it?
No,
I,
I had control of the premises.
I was standing right at the front door,
but the house was in and I had to keep
the door open and I was stuck with that
for about five hours.
It
was only three days.
And he got that bad in
three days with heat.
Yeah.
And,
and
what,
what was the summer?
Yeah,
so somebody just decided to do that to
accelerate the deterioration process.
Who knows?
Uh,
the guy was dead on the floor and he
had a marble lamp base embedded in his
skull.
Oh Shit.
So he's on the floor,
flatten.
The lamp is sticking up
like this and Oh my God,
I'm stuck with sky.
And I was talking to him for three or
four hours until the embedded in his
skull.
Who killed him?
A lover.
It was a homosexual killing Holla.
Yeah.
Look at that.
It's a safety and gayness.
No,
dude,
we're looking to kill you
if you fuck other dudes.
Um,
yeah.
So that,
that's,
that's one that really stands out.
I was in two shootings and a lot
of fights and a two shootings.
Where you got shot at?
No,
a first shooting was a
guy trying to run me down,
chasing me across the street with a car.
I mean she wrong side of the street and
we were using a Smith and Wesson 38 one
58 grain lead ball ammo.
My,
it's terrible bullet.
It's soft leaded.
It ricocheted and bounced
off the guy's windshield.
Oh my God.
A second shooting was a drug dealer.
Sick to attack dogs on my
partner and I and I and,
and I killed the dogs she needs,
I didn't hesitate.
I just shot the shit out of the dogs.
My partner was grateful.
Yeah.
You've had a crazy life too.
Oh yeah,
man.
I've,
I've done,
you never finished telling us
about why you went to Venezuela.
Was that about the Pat Tillman story?
Yeah,
that was,
um,
well,
not only Pat Tillman,
but I was,
uh,
you were one of the first people to
break the fact that Pat Tillman was not
killed in combat was in fact
killed by friendly fire.
Pat Tillman's mom,
Danny.
Uh,
is what she goes by.
Mary Tillman,
uh,
sent me an email,
I'm trying to get in touch with
my military affairs editor,
Stan Golf,
who Stan Golf as a retired master sergeant
from US Army Special Forces Delta who
taught at West Point
stands a great friend.
He's a brilliant writer,
but one of the best writers
I wonderful human being.
I love the guy.
And she was trying to get in touch
with Stan through from the wilderness.
And we had done a lot of expos ace.
And I went down to San Jose and I'm met
with Danny and she gave me like 2000
plus pages of army records redacted,
you know,
how black spots.
And so I spent the night copying those,
um,
every one of them in perfect order
and I thousand,
how long did that take?
You do what you gotta do.
And uh,
so I copied him,
took them back to our offices in Ashland,
Oregon.
And I flew Stan golf out and a standard,
most of the work,
but we totally broke down the army story.
And we published a seven part series,
which was the basis of Henry
Waxman's hearings in the House,
governmental affairs committee over,
uh,
the,
the cover up and we brought,
we got to six senior officers,
three general officer's a disciplined
and we forced on Roosevelt to resign.
Well we were,
we were,
that's why Donald Ross summer resigned.
Oh yeah,
he resigned right when he was about to
be called before the Tillman hearings.
Very suddenly.
So then he can't be called
because he resigned.
And is that how you avoided it?
I'm sorry.
Is it an amazing when they
have weird rules like that,
like Congress,
like they can insider trade.
It's not illegal for Congress to be inside
of trading is his resignation was the
quid pro quo.
You know,
he fell on his sword
because it went to Bush.
He had went to Chaney and Bush,
um,
and uh,
a lot of crimes were covered with that.
That was just a horrendous miscarriage.
And you believe that it was an accident
or do you believe that they killed him
on purpose because he was
being very outspoken about his?
No,
I what I believe is,
and I think enough time has
passed where I can say this.
Uh,
and again,
I know a great many people in the
service and I know special forces.
I know rangers and I know a lot of guys.
Pat Tillman had a very large ego.
He was very outspoken.
He had all the right ideas.
He knew the war was bullshit.
He was talking out about it,
but he was saying they fracked them.
I think that Pat Tillman became a
ranger before he became a soldier.
If that means anything to you,
it's like putting on a black
belt before you earn the green,
you know?
Uh,
uh,
and it was definitely a
really fubar situation.
I don't think it was a
planned premeditated murder.
Uh,
but I do kind of suspect that,
uh,
his,
his last words were,
I'm Pat fucking Tillman and that's one
of three round burst hit him in the head,
you know,
and so very sad,
very tragic.
And the people shooting
had this communication.
The guy that shot him was a
sergeant in his own cereal,
a shooting,
a three round burst out of assault squad,
automatic weapon,
30 yards.
Of course he knew what was going on.
So you think he killed them?
Yeah.
Wow.
Holy Shit.
And you think he killed him?
Just because he was too outspoken,
too.
Cocky didn't want it and
they didn't like him.
Fuck you.
That's too much speculation.
Who knows?
Right.
But they using,
they killed them.
Yeah,
but not premeditated murder in,
in,
in that sense.
But what we do know is that
what the army did after that,
they destroyed evidence.
They burned his clothing.
They immediately started the write
up for a silver star and all of that
criminality that followed,
rather than admit that he was killed
in a friendly fire accident by his own
people.
So were you the catalyst that forced
them to admit that it was friendly fire?
Well,
stand.
Let's give the credit where
it's due to stand Goff.
I was the publisher and the editor.
In other words,
I put my money in my balls on the line
and gave Stan golf everything he needed
to write a seven part series,
the tour,
the U S Army and Donald Rumsfeld,
new assholes.
So you,
you publish it in from the Wilderness.
It's,
it's still on the website to this day.
All seven parts.
And when we were in the Er,
just ready to publish part five,
my offices were burglarized.
All seven of my computers were smashed.
Uh,
one of my employees turned out of woman,
turned out to be trying to set me
up on a sexual harassment charge.
There was a forge police report.
Falsified police report connected to you.
You weren't trying to show her your both?
No.
So the girl,
um,
when,
when do you think that they came
to her and offered her something?
I think she,
she was a plant.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
they have plants,
man.
It sounds ridiculous.
But there was a bunch of growers
in northern California and,
uh,
they had a guy who would like
sit in on their meetings,
you know,
they would talk about like,
you gotta have grown for the community.
It's found out that guy was a cop
because he died in a motorcycle accident.
The guy died.
And then they said,
that's our buddy at the fuck.
And then sergeant fuck face
and spying on the whole time.
Yeah.
We'll use embedded in
a bunch of pot growers
like,
you know,
talk about a waste of resources back to
back to Venezuela when computers were
smashed.
Um,
uh,
my life was in danger and it was
obvious the only thing that could have
prevented us from finishing the Tillman
series would have been my death.
Okay.
So,
uh,
and I knew that they
were coming after me and,
and uh,
and so I went to
Venezuela because Hugo go,
Chavez had spent like the last four
years going like that to George Bush and
Dick Cheney and tissue
actually hang out with,
you know,
I,
I never met him.
That was a really,
really hard,
a difficult time.
I was poisoned down.
Their foreign ministry
knew I was in the country.
I asked for help,
but they wouldn't touch me.
They didn't want to contaminate me.
They being poisoned with him.
Um,
once was a drug called Buhloone Donga,
which is the root drug was
cupola mean you could look it up.
Uh,
there was another,
uh,
unknown etiology.
The Cuban doctors help,
but it was shutting down all,
all of my plans was systems.
My adrenals were shutting down.
My Lips were shutting down to die.
Yeah.
So I came back,
I came back to the u s in a,
actually to Canada
first.
It was so hoping you to say Fox,
Madison,
that's a badge of,
that's who was,
I'm going to hear Fox medicine forever.
I know.
That's a,
that's a meme right now,
son.
Okay.
That's right up there with Giorgio.
Sucralose is hair.
So,
and uh,
but I,
I got it.
I was sick for probably
a full year after I came.
Holy Shit.
And I did holistic and as much as I could,
but I was hot.
So you get,
you got to death's door essentially,
and there was nothing
they could do to save you,
then nobody knew what the
fuck are the Cuban doctors is.
We don't know what's causing this.
Wow.
That's incredible.
That's so terrifying.
But we got Tillman out and Tillman was
published and right after Donald Rumsfeld
resigned,
I flew back to Canada.
Then I came back to New York and stayed
in Brooklyn for 14 months before I came
back out to,
to venison.
So will you just moving around just
because you were worried about someone
finding where you were?
Uh,
no,
I,
you know,
Venezuela was a very
specific purpose because,
you know,
I was,
we had something huge with Tillman and,
and,
and I was sort of like an events.
They were going to kill me.
How long did you stay in Vat as well?
Four months.
Uh,
and then I was basically out of it.
you know,
I was done,
uh,
food.
I came into an inheritance from my father
or that I had to fight for for three
years,
but in 2008 and I,
and I had this time,
this first time in like 30 fucking years
of fighting to breathe and catch my
breath.
I have to worry about shit.
And so I kind of caught up with myself,
you know,
it's like you stop long enough and then
all your shit you did for like the last
three catches up and you absorb it.
Um,
and then,
uh,
was right about then that,
Cynthia McKinney,
my friend,
black,
former black congresswoman from Georgia,
Atlanta,
very dear friend,
she was the Green party nominee in,
and she mentioned that she might like
to have me be a running mate in 2008.
I said,
are you out of your mind?
But that's when I decided,
well,
we need a presidential energy policy.
This needs to get put into the peak
oil and all the issues about this.
And that became my book
confronting collapse.
But then Chris Smith showed up from
blue mark films also in February of
[inaudible] nine,
uh,
and said,
hey,
we'd Kinda like to make a
movie what's going on in it,
right.
Compelling movie.
And you think about a man who,
when the last time you saw a movie
where a dude just talks for 90 minutes,
pretty fucking amazing.
And you can carry a movie
like that and not just carry,
but it was really entertaining
as well as fucking terrifying.
You know,
there were five shoots.
Each shoot was about
12 to 14 hours on set.
It was a full Hollywood shoe.
So you would just drink coffee
and smoke cigarettes and rant.
Yeah.
And they were feeding me the
energy drinks and they'd have him.
It was so cold when we
first started shooting,
you know,
I'm in that blue suit,
right.
I would be sitting there and I cut.
They bring in a blanket,
put two butane heaters
next to me until the color
came back and then pull it out and then
start shooting again once when I was,
uh,
working for a Dave Chappelle.
Did the Dave Chappelle show was filmed
this a fear factor of parody with Tyrone.
Big Ums is the crack head that he used
to do the character and he was on fear
factor and we were doing this in a
warehouse in Brooklyn and it was fucking
freezing man.
And we all like huddled in front of these
blast furnaces and then I would have
to get out there in a short
sleeve shirt and you know,
or whatever the fuck I was
wearing at the time and be like,
I was on fear factor and
we were phrasing mad.
I mean,
yeah,
that's not good Brian.
That's a bad impression.
Um,
that's uh,
that's incredible man.
So you,
you've really,
uh,
you've seen a lot of crazy
shit in your life from,
from the La police time to now to having
a movie made about you just sitting
there talking like,
what a,
what a crazy ride it's been
from being a cop to this.
How that,
how the fuck,
how did you get to this point,
man?
Is this your destiny?
You do you feel it at certain point
in time obligated to disseminate this
information?
Oh,
well this is the three stooges,
school of spiritual level ocean.
I mean it's like I have no doubt that
something larger than me tapped me and,
and,
and gave you the ball.
Yeah.
And,
and has kept me and sustain me and really
kind of made jokes of any other plans
that I had along the way for what I
thought I wanted to do with my life.
Um,
and I'm really aware of that
now and I'm living that,
you know,
spiritually connected to the fact that,
there is something really good out here.
There is something that's showing itself
on this planet now that's just in that
it's fair and that it's loving.
It does have power,
I'm seeing.
Correct.
It's like watching the matrix,
you know,
when the,
when the Matrix start on that little
bits of light start coming through and,
and,
and you know,
and all these people out
here in the world right now,
they're living in a matrix that's
falling apart exactly like it did in the
movie.
It's like,
oh,
wait a minute,
that there's a big hole in
that building over there.
And there's this,
that's metaphorically what we're
seeing happen all around us.
And there's a lot of people who really
get that they're in a matrix and are
starting to move out.
And there's others who are equally moved
to try and go back and reinforce it.
And those are people
making their own choices.
I think about which way
they're going to go.
So you're not pessimistic,
you're optimistic.
A lot of people might think that
you're a doom and gloom guy,
but you're now you're know you're,
you're,
let's be happy.
We're going to get rid of the bad system.
We're going to get rid of the bad guy.
There is a balancing that is taking place.
It's long overdue.
It's a,
it's as a doc holiday would say.
It's a reckoning.
What an amazing time to be alive.
You know,
it really is.
It's an amazing time to be,
uh,
at the point in human history and the
history of this planet and the history of,
you know,
it just,
it's all very strange that it's all
taking place in our lifetime right now.
And this is a really,
it's an amazing moment.
You know,
I hope we get through it.
Cool.
I hope we all keep our eyes open because,
uh,
even though these are
the darkest of times,
this is also an age of miracles and we
need to just keep ourselves open to the
expectation that good things can
happen without our permission.
And there's wisdoms.
Uh,
you know,
there's a lot of other
wisdom out here in this.
There's a lot of light shone through and
that's one of the reasons why occupied.
Just just,
you know,
makes my toes wiggle.
There's never been a time in human
history where the access to information is
easier.
And when the access to
information is easy,
people can get the truth out.
When people can get the truth out and
they can get ideas out and they can get an
ideology of happiness
and of sustaining your,
your,
you know,
your environment and of,
of,
of subsistence and of a community
and of love and friendship,
it's very possible to
foster that and grow.
You know,
we don't have to all be conquerors.
We don't have to be all
caught raping the world.
It doesn't have to be that way.
That's right.
Right.
We can just be human beings and enjoy
our time here because it is in fact
temporary and like all sorts of patterns
of behavior that people get stuck in,
whether it's fucking gambling or excessive
masturbation or whatever the fuck you
get hooked on.
You can also get hooked
on running the world.
on fucking over the world.
So these people are sick.
They're sick,
and they need to wake up,
need to pay attention to Michael Ruper
bitches because he just dropped some
science.
Thank you,
sir.
That was awesome.
That was great time,
man.
There was one of my
favorite podcasts ever.
He said some awesome shit.
And we do pleasure.
I,
man,
we've been doing it for
two hours and 40 minutes.
She,
I just,
you know,
I,
I just got so you could sit for 16 hours
of the freezing fucking cold and belt
out a movie star.
All right.
Five Times.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
thank you very much,
man.
This was awesome.
Thank you.
Thank you to the flashlight
for sponsoring the podcast.
Go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link
for the flashlight and you get 15% off
number one.
So I told her from an old hall and thank
you to onnit.com that's o n n I t.com.
Makers of Alpha brain,
makers of shroom Tech Sport,
the cordyceps mushrooms,
a supplement for endurance
shroom tech immune,
which is a different kind of mushroom
that's great for your immune system.
And we also have new mood,
which is a five HTP supplement.
As always,
there's a hundred percent money back
guarantee on anything from on.com.
Thanks for tuning in.
Chicago theater almost sold out freaks.
We had to open up the top balcony.
The bottom has done kid.
That is February.
No excuse me.
January 27th it's Duncan Trussell,
Joey Diaz and me.
We're coming to the Chicago theater.
Strap yourself in hookers cause we're
bringing thunder Michael Rubric.
You're the fucking man.
Thank you very much sir.
I appreciate it greatly.
How can people follow you?
Do you have a Twitter?
You don't have a Twitter,
do you?
We got everything.
Yeah.
But you can find
everything@collapsenet.com [inaudible]
collapsed net.com.
What is your Twitter?
I want to follow you on Twitter
Max is my Twitter collapse.
Net collapse net.
What about Michael Rubric?
Was that taken Michael?
See Rupert on Twitter.
Would that be
better than collapse net?
So that way people could
look you up tiny late.
Somebody just jacked it right now as
we said that some little hacks or kid.
I got it.
Huh?
Well there's an,
there's an actor named
Michael Rupert and yeah,
it was a photog named Mike Michael Rupert.
That's why I use the seat
because they just didn't get it.
You know,
people calling them up saying
you're crazy conspiracy
Harlow conspiracy theory and it's a scene.
What are the odds?
I got a show this Friday at
the icehouse here with uh,
some people I can't talk about,
but tickets are on sale right now.
How can we keep talking about the people?
Yeah.
Oh,
cause it's a surprise.
you don't know who the
fuck's on me on the show?
No,
I do.
You gotta wait you to say that's
how you advertise your fuck.
Well,
I'll be announcing a few of them on
Twitter in the next couple of days.
Trying to get people
to follow your Twitter.
Is that what you're doing?
No,
no,
no.
Rick.
Now there's other people who was on the,
God damn sure.
I can't,
I cannot because there's
a reason why I came.
The reason sucks.
I know.
Can you explain the reason?
Um,
because there's other bigger
shows around the same day.
Can't advertise and they
don't want to be like,
oh,
you could see me 50 bucks.
Here it be a good show.
That's why I just do it.
I mean,
I have those shows.
I just do them anyway here.
Yeah.
Tell people to stop being pussies.
Tell people where the
fuck are you going to be.
Right.
Right back a rubric.
But goddammit icehouse
commie.com for tickets.
Everlast from the house of pain.
We're going to try to
get him in this week.
Shit.
Yeah,
he's,
he's awesome.
And uh,
we'll,
we'll do at least two podcasts this week.
All right.
I love you freaks.
See you soon.
Bye.
Thank you Michael Rubric.
You were awesome.